WELCOME TO THE JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY AND THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON SMALL BUSINESS AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP I AM ASSEMBLY
WOMAN COUNTY PETRIE-NORRIS A
CHAIRED THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
SMALL BUSINESS AND JOINING ME
IN CONVENING THIS HEARING IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES CHAIR AND THE
ASSEMBLY'S JOB. COMMITTEE WE
ARE ALSO JOINED TODAY BY APPLE
WE WILL BE JOINED BY A NUMBER
OF MEMBERS FROM OUR TWO
COMMITTEES- WE'RE CURRENTLY
JOINED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE
SINCE MATH. GOOD TO SEE YOU AND
ALSO JOINING US TODAY OUR
MEMBERS OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
POLICY STAFF INCLUDING TWENTY
SIMONS THE CHIEF CONSULTANT
WITH THE ASSEMBLY JOBS
COMMITTEE. LIZZIE COULD SENATE
THE LEGISLATIVE AIDE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
SMALL BUSINESS AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP KAYLA TEEPLE
POLICY INTERN WITH THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON SMALL
BUSINESS AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
AND JANET YELLEN THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS POLICY CONSULTANT AT
THANKS FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK IN NOT PUTTING THIS
HEARING TOGETHER REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION. IN
THE COMMITTEE OFFICE WE ARE
BEING SUPPORTED BY JD JEFFRIES
WITH THE ASSEMBLY JOBS
COMMITTEE R. PLEASE NOTE THAT
JUDY IS AVAILABLE TO ASSIST
ANYONE WHO IS HAVING A PROBLEM
CONNECTING WITH OUR LIVE
STREAM. OR WHO WILL BE CALLING
INTO THE HEARING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT SHE CAN BE REACHED AT
ANY TIME AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE ZERO I
NOW THAT WE'VE DISPENSES
MINUTES HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS WILL
GO AHEAD AND CONTINUE WITH OUR
OPENING REMARKS. I'D SURE
CERVANTES PLEASE COULD YOU
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
HEARING AND FRAME THE KEY
ISSUES. THAT WE'RE GOING TO
DIVE INTO TODAY. THANK YOU
MADAM TODAY'S HERE IS THIS. IN
A SERIES OF HEARINGS. BY THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
SMALL BUSINESS AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND THE THIRD
HEARING FOR THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JOBS. IN WHICH WE
ARE EXAMINING THE IMPACT OF
KOBE NINETEEN ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SUPPORT A MORE
INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC RECOVERY. IN
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL BE
TAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC ON WOMEN
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT A
COMPONENT OF OUR INVESTIGATION
WHILE. THE PANDEMIC IT'S
CERTAINLY A SIGNIFICANT EVENT
TO ALL BUSINESSES WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES FACED
GREAT CHALLENGES PRIOR TO COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES HAVE
ROUTINELY HAD AN EQUAL ACCESS
TO CAPITAL. AS WELL AS TO
PUBLIC PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
WHICH SHOULD HAVE HELPED
ADDRESS THE HISTORIC UNDER
INVESTMENT IN LOW INCOME AREAS
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES IN GENERAL. SO AS
WE CONSIDER HOW TO BETTER
SUPPORT OUR WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC ROADBLOCKS
AS WELL AS THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. DURING THE
PANDEMIC. NATIONAL DATA IS NOW%
AVAILABLE THAT SHOWS THE
EXTREME DEGREE TO WHICH THE
PANDEMIC HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BUSINESS OWNERS OF
COLOR. BETWEEN FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY IN APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
THE NUMBER OF ACTIVE BLACK
OWNED BUSINESSES DECLINED FORTY
BUSINESSES DECLINED 32% AND
ASIAN OWNED BUSINESSES DROPPED
25% VERSUS 21% FOR BUSINESSES
OVERALL. IN CALIFORNIA IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT MORE THAN
NINETEEN THOUSAND BUSINESSES.
HAVE HAVE REALLY I'D SHUT THEIR
DOORS PERMANENTLY EXCUSE ME.
AMONG THOSE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES THERE ARE A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF BUSINESSES OWNED
BY WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL REASONS
FOR THIS THAT I WILL HIGHLIGHT.
FIRST BUSINESSES OWNED BY WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR TEND TO BE
SMALLER AND OF A YOUNGER TENURE
THAN BUSINESSES OVERALL. NOT
SURPRISINGLY EARLY STAGE
BUSINESSES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
TEND TO BE LESS RESILIENT IN
TIMES OF ECONOMIC STRESS.
SECOND ONE MINUTE MY NORTE ON
BUSINESSES PREDOMINANTLY LIVE
WITHIN THE BUSINESS SECTORS
THAT HAVE LOWER BARRIERS TO
ENTRY. WHICH ALSO HAPPENED TO
BE THE SAME BUSINESS SECTORS
THAT WERE HARDEST HIT DURING
THE INITIAL MONTHS OF THE
PANDEMIC INCLUDING OUR FOOD OF
SERVICES AND PERSONAL SERVICES
SUCH AS HAIR SALONS. THIRD DATA
SHOWS THAT WOMEN HAVE IN
GENERAL FOR AND I'M EVEN BURDEN
RELATIVE TO THE CARE OF SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN AND OLDER ADULTS
WHO HAVE NEEDED ADDITIONAL CARE
AND ATTENTION DURING THE
PANDEMIC. IN OUR EARLIER
HEARINGS COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE
BRIEFED ON KEY ELEMENTS OF IT
COULD BE NINETEEN ECONOMY
INCLUDING IMPACTS ON
SIGNIFICANT INDUSTRY SECTORS
AND STAKEHOLDER INITIATIVES
INTENDED TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES RECOVERY. TODAY'S
HEARING BUILDS ON MANY OF THESE
SAME THEMES AND DELVES MORE
DEEPLY DEEPLY INTO THE
PANDEMIC'S IMPACT ON WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES AND
STRATEGIES TO REDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES. TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT WORK WE HAVE DIVIDED
THE HEARING INTO THREE PARTS
FOLLOWED BY PUBLIC COMMENT. IN
THE FIRST PANEL WE WILL FOCUS
ON THE GENERAL HEALTH AND
CAPACITY OF WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES TO ADOPT TO
THE KOBE NINETEEN ECONOMY. THIS
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY CASE
STUDIES ON HOW ONE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION IS
USING SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED ETHNIC COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING THE CREATION OF A
RETAIL AND COMMERCIAL FOOD
INCUBATOR. IN THE FINAL PANEL
THERE WILL BE NO FORMAL
PRESENTATION WILL BE JUMPING
RIGHT INTO A DIRECT DIALOGUE
BETWEEN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THE PANELIST. THIS PANEL
FEATURES TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND A REGIONAL COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION WHOSE
MISSION IS TO EMPOWER WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES. ALL
TOLD I THINK THIS IS GOING TO
BE A VERY INFORMATIVE A COUPLE
OF HOURS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
TRANSITION IT BACK TO OUR
CHAIR. WELL THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AS WE ALL KNOW AND- AS
WE HEARD IN THE FIRST HEARING
OF OUR SELECT COMMITTEE ON
SMALL BUSINESS AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO. WE KNOW THAT ATTICA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES UP AND DOWN
THIS STATE I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT NO ONE HAS FELT THE
EFFECTS OF THIS PANDEMIC. TO
THE DEGREE THAT ARE MINORITY
AND WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES
HAPPEN AND CHAIRS. LAID OUT AS
SOME OF THE REASONS FOR THAT
AND SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
ARE WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES FACE AS WE REBUILD
ANDBEGIN TO RECOVER. AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT OUR ABILITY TO STABILIZE
THESE SMALLEST OF BUSINESSES
ARE THESE WITH THIS LEASE MOST
VULNERABLE SECTORS. AND
POSITION TO THRIVE AS WE EMERGE
FROM THIS PANDEMIC IT'S GOING
TO BE CRITICAL NOT JUST TO THE
WELFARE OF THESE INDIVIDUAL
BUSINESSES BUT- FOR THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY- SO I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
DIVING INTO. TODAY'S
CONVERSATION AND TO EXPLORING
POLICY PROPOSALS AND SOLUTIONS
THAT TIME THAT WE AS
LEGISLATORS CAN AN AXE AND PUSH
FORWARD IN THE CAPITAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING A
SWIFT I JUST AND EQUITABLE.
RECOVERY AND DATA BEFORE WE GET
STARTED I REALLY WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THE SPEAKERS YOU'RE
GOING TO BE JOINING US HERE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME
TO. SHARE YOUR EXPERTISE AND
YOUR EXPERIENCE ON THIS TOPIC I
YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT AREA OF WORK REALLY.
IS VALUED I FOUR WEEKS JUMP IN
OUR FOR PANEL. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
AN OPENING COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. I AM
JUST LOOKING. I'M IN ORDER TO
THE INFORMATION THAT WE'RE
GOING TO RECEIVE TODAY IS
CRITICAL FOR WOMEN IN BUSINESS
WOMEN OF COLOR IN SMALL
BUSINESS AND GENERAL NEWS WAS
BROKEN UP WE ALL STRUGGLE TO
CALIFORNIA'S WE'RE GOING TO DO
ALL THE HELP THAT WE CAN IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP OUR
BUSINESSES STATE CALIFORNIA SO
I LOOK FOR THAT INFORMATION.
THANK YOU I HAVE MY NUMBER AND
THAT THE FOUR WEEK WE GET
STARTED JUST A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
FIRST LET ME DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE ONLINE
BRIEFING MATERIALS PREPARED BY
COMMITTEE STAFF AMONG OTHER
INFORMATION YOU WILL FIND- AN
OVERVIEW OF THE STATE ECONOMY
AND OF THE INCREASING CHALLENGE
INCOME INEQUALITY IS POSING FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. A
PROFILE ON SMALL BUSINESSES
INCLUDING WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES AS WELL AS
SPECIAL TABS ON THE STATE'S FOR
BILLION DOLLAR SMALL BUSINESS
KEVIN NINETEEN GRANT PROGRAM
AND OTHER RELATED LEGISLATION
AND BUDGET ACTIONS OUT LASTLY
TO HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS FIRST DUE
TO THE COVE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
PROTOCOLS WE ARE REQUIRING
MASKS TO BE WORN BY EVERYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. AND IF YOU DO
DO NOT HAVE A MASS TODAY WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU AND SECOND
FOR THOSE WATCHING HEARING WHO
WISH TO SPEAK DURING PUBLIC
COMMENT DURING PUBLIC TESTIMONY
THAT'S GOING TO BE AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AND AT THAT TIME
THE TOLL FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN AND THIS PUBLIC ACCESS
NUMBER IS ALSO POSTED ON THE
JEDI WEBSITE I WE DO ANTICIPATE
TAKING UP AGENDA ITEM FIVE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. AROUND THE
FOUR O'CLOCK HOUR WE'VE
SCHEDULED UP TO THIRTY MINUTES
OF A HEARING FOR PUBLIC AND
STAKEHOLDER COMMENTS- AND WITH
THAT I BELIEVE WE ARE READY TO
DIVE INTO OUR FIRST PANEL AND-
SURE CERVANTES ALTERNATE. BACK
TO YOU TO WELCOME OUR SPEAKERS.
IF OUR PANEL WAS CAN COME TO
THE PRO. TAPE SO THAT CAN BE
AGENDA ITEM. TO EXCELLENCE WE
HAVE MASTER FIRST PANEL TO
DISCUSS THE CHALLENGES WOMEN
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
HAVE IN STARTING AND GROWING
THEIR BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON THE LAST
SIXTEEN MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC.
JOINING US THIS AFTERNOON ARE
THREE EXPERIENCED LEADERS
WITHIN THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY INCLUDING EUGENE
CORNELIUS JUNIOR SENIOR
DIRECTOR CENTER FOR THE
REGIONAL ECONOMICS AND
CALIFORNIA CENTER MILKEN
INSTITUTE. WE HAVE NANCY SWIFT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR JEFFERSON
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT INSTITUTE
AND CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER NETWORK
AND POP FONG SHE DIED PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN
PACIFIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. IN
ADDITION TO LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK FOR SUBSEQUENT
AGENDA ITEMS WE HAVE ALSO ASKED
OUR PANELISTS TO IDENTIFY KEY
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT NEEDS AND
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERATION. BY
THE END OF THE HEARING OUR
GOALS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHETHER WE HAVE THE RIGHT MIX
OF PROGRAMS ARE THEY
SUFFICIENTLY FUNDED AND ARE
THESE CHANGES ARE THERE ANY
CHANGES THAT NEED TO BE MADE TO
BETTER SERVE THE NEEDS OF WOMEN
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES.
ALTHOUGH I WILL BE PROVIDING A
BRIEF INTRODUCTION OF EACH
PANELIST LET ME REMIND MEMBERS
THAT THEY HAVE COPIES OF OUR
PANELISTS BIOGRAPHIES AFTER GAS
AS WELL AS POSTED ON THE
HEARINGS WEBSITE. OUR FIRST
PANELIST IS MISTER EUGENE
CORNELIUS JUNIOR WHO SERVES AS
THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR REGIONAL ECONOMICS
AT THE MILKEN INSTITUTE WHERE
HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL SMALL BUSINESS
POLICY COORDINATION. PRIOR TO
THIS ROLE HE HAS A
DISTINGUISHED CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE MOST RECENTLY A SENIOR
ADVISER TO THE OFFICE OF
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AT THE U.
S. SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION MISTER
CORNELIUS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
GOTTEN. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THINK YOU'RE SIMPLY
FOR INVITING US TO THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. THE CALL THE
NINETEENTH TAMPA AND EMIC AND
SUBSEQUENT LOCK DOWN AND DEMAND
SHOCK RESULTED IN SHELTERING
BUSINESSES BOTH TEMPORARILY AND
PERMANENTLY. AMONG THE HARDEST
HIT WERE SMALL BUSINESSES. ILL
EQUIPPED TO NAVIGATE THROUGH
THE SUDDEN DISRUPTION. AND EVEN
FURTHER WAS WOMEN AND
MINORITIES WHO DID NOT HAVE
DIRECT RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY AND
AVAILABLE TO THEM AT THE TIME.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT ROUGHLY
328% OF SMALL BUSINESSES CLOSED
LAOS BEGAN IN ABSOLUTELY
FOREVER MANY SMALL BUSINESSES
AND COLLECTIVELY EMPLOY DECAL
COMPLEX I'M SORRY LET ME START
OVER THAT COLLECTIVELY EMPLOY.
OVER SIX MILLION WORKERS
NATIONALLY. WHAT INSURED WAS AN
UNUSUALLY HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE. AND THAT PEAKED IN APRIL
OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY X.
FOURTEEN POINT 8% THE HIGHEST
RATE OBSERVED SINCE DATA WAS
COLLECTED BEGINNING IN NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT. NO THAT ISN'T
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT TWO THIRDS OF ALL
NEW JOBS CREATED AFTER THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE WERE CREATED. BY
SMALL BUSINESSES AND 40% OF
THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES WERE
WOMEN AND OF THAT 40% WOMEN 70%
WERE WOMEN OF COLOR. EDIT
EMPLOYMENT IS LINKED TO THIS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE
TEND TO HIRE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CULTURALLY OR SENSIBILITY OR
CUTE OR LOCATED WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SELF IN RESPONSE
TO THIS ECONOMIC FALLOUT. OF
THE CLOVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
POLICYMAKERS PASSED THE CULVERT
A RELIEF AND ECONOMIC SECURITY
ACT. A TWO POINT TWO TRILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMIC STIMULUS. FROM
THE VERY START THIS POLICY
INTERVENTION WAS LIMITED IN
THAT IT WAS REACTIVE. RATHER
THAN PROACTIVE PRESCRIPTIVE
VERSUS N. F. AND THESE FINDINGS
SUGGEST THAT MACRO ECONOMIC
TOOLS STIMULATING AGGRESSIVE
DEMAND OR PROVIDING LIQUIDITY
LIMITED THE ABILITY TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES. YOU HAVE THE
FOR YOU A PRESENTATION THAT I
HAVE MAPPED OUT AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT YOU TAKE THE TIME TO
REALLY GO OVER THE DETAILS OF
IT BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE THINGS
SAYS AND IT. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I THINK A. WE HAVE.
OVER FOUR POINT ONE MILLION
SMALL BUSINESSES. OKAY. RIGHT
THERE THANK YOU. A. N. SMALL
BUSINESSES NATIONWIDE
REPRESENTS 44% OF THE GROSS
NATIONAL PRODUCT SO THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDER AN
ESSENTIAL FOR OUR ECONOMY. HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD REPRESENT
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES REPRESENT
99% OF ALL BUSINESS ALL
EMPLOYERS ROUGHLY FOUR POINT
ONE MILLION BUSINESSES. AND
THEY HAVE BEEN HIT HARD AND
THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED A REVENUE
DROP. IN THE MANAGER MAGNITUDE
OF 45% DURING THE PERIOD OF
JANUARY. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
AND MAY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
WITH A THIRTY FIVE POINT NINE
CLOSURE RATE DURING THE SAME
TIME. THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
RANKS ELEVENTH AMONG FIFTIES
EIGHT STATE AT FORTY EIGHT
STATES. IN THE NATION NO
OVERALL CLOSER. MEANWHILE. THE
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
PARTICULARLY THE P. P. P. LONG
PROGRAM AVERAGED ABOUT THE SAME
PERCENTAGE OF VOLUME OF THE
PREVIOUS SB A LOANS TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS. THIS
EMPHASIZES THE NEED FOR THE
STATE LEVEL ACTION TO HELP WITH
THIS RECOVERY AND TO HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES. AS WE DIVE DOWN
INTO THOSE NUMBERS. I DON'T
KNOW FOR A YEAR. WE WILL SEE
THAT BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
AVERAGED ABOUT 528% OF SB A
LOANS OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS
AND THAT WAS THE SAME FOR THE
PPP PROGRAM. IF YOU LOOK AT
SPAGO FOR LOANS IF YOU LOOK AT
SEVEN A. LOANS. AND THEN YOU
LOOK AT THE P. P. P. LOANS
THERE WAS A LITTLE UP TICK IN
THE LATINO COMMUNITY. AS FAR AS
P. P. LOANS BUT THE AMOUNT OF
LOANS GIVEN TO THE- WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER. BASED ON
THIS DATA WE KNOW THAT. WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THE-
REVENUES THAT WERE ACROSS THE
STATE. IF WE COULD GO TO THE
CHART WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
CLINTON. BASED ON THESE
INFORMATION BASED ON THE LACK
OF INFORMATION ABOUT LACK OF
RELATIONSHIPS WITH BANKS WHICH
THE PPP PROGRAM PREDICATED
ITSELF ON BUSINESSES HAVING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH BANKS AND
MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND WOMEN
NOT HAVING THOSE SIGNIFICATIVA
LICENSES AS OTHERS THEY
DISPROPORTIONATELY GOT NOT ONLY
A LOWER AMOUNT. PERCENTAGE WISE
BUT THEY GOT A LOWER DOLLAR
AMOUNT IN IN LOANS TO HELP. SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT CAN THE
STATE LEGISLATOR WHAT CAN YOU
DO TO HELP THESE COMMUNITIES
AND WHAT THESE COMMUNITY NEEDS
IN GOING FORWARD AND THERE'S
THESE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
BREAK DOWN THE INDUSTRIES THAT
THIS INVOLVED. BECAUSE THEY
WERE 90% OF THIS EMPLOYMENT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES OKAY FROM
LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY. 67% OF
THE WORKERS EMPLOYED IN THIS
INDUSTRY ARE MINORITIES.
INDUSTRIES IT THE INDUSTRY
EMPLOYS DECLINED 19% BETWEEN
JANUARY. TWO THOUSAND TEN
TWENTY AND ENGINE TWENTY ONE.
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT WHEN WE
LOOK AT THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT
PROFESSIONAL AND BUSINESS
SERVICES INDUSTRY 81% OF
EMPLOYMENT COMES FROM SMALL
BUSINESSES AND 49% OF THE
WORKERS IN THOSE INDUSTRIES ARE
MINORITIES. THE INDUSTRY
EMPLOYMENT DECLINE ALL LESS
THAN 1% IN BETWEEN THE SAME
PERIOD OF JANUARY TWENTIETH AND
JANUARY AND JUNE. TWENTY ONE.
SO THERE ARE THREE THINGS THAT
I BELIEVE ARE LOW HANGING FRUIT
WITHIN THE REACH OF THIS
ASSEMBLY. THAT CAN BE DONE
BECAUSE WE IN CALIFORNIA.
REALLY HAVE DONE A LOT TO
ASSIST SMALL BUSINESSES AND I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD DISCREDIT
THAT WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE AND WHAT WE
CAN IMPROVE ON. N. THE NUMBER
ONE THING I THINK WE CAN DO IS
USE TECHNOLOGY. WE CAN MAP
ACCESS TO CAPITAL TO SMALL
BUSINESSES COLLECTED DATA
ORGANIZE A PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE
DATABASE AND MAINTAIN A WEBSITE
WHICH COULD BE EITHER DONE BY A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY OR THIRD
PARTY- INDEPENDENT- GROUP OF
CONTRACTORS THIS WILL BE TO
PROVIDE READY AND CURRENT
INFORMATION ON WHERE AVAILABLE
CAPITAL IS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND RELATED CONTACT INFORMATION
TO CONNECT THEM TO THE BANKERS
AND LENDERS AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS IT. WITHIN THEIR
EXIT OUT. THE SECOND THING WE
COULD DO IS WE CAN PROVIDE
REFUNDABLE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDITS FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND START UP.
SOME SMALL BUSINESSES CAN'T
UTILIZED EXISTING R&D TAX
CREDIT BECAUSE THEY FACE LITTLE
TO NO TAX BURDEN. PARTICULARLY
START UPS AND THE PRE REVENUE
STAGE. TARGETING POLICIES TO.
REFINE A PERCENTAGE OF THAT I'M
USED RESEARCH CREDIT. COULD
FACILITATE GREATER INVESTMENT
WITH THE POTENTIAL OF
GENERATING FUTURE REVENUES. THE
THIRD. RECOMMENDATION IS TO
ENHANCE THE SMALL BUSINESS
UTILIZATION PROGRAM. ELEVATE
THE SMALL BUSINESS LIAISON ROLE
ALREADY ESTABLISHED IN EVERY
STATE AGENCY. TO A FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT POSITION WHICH IS
CURRENTLY. I PART TIME DUTY OR
OTHER ASSIGNED DUTY RIGHT- THEY
DISPOSITION TO A SENIOR LEVEL
MANAGEMENT POSITION WITH DIRECT
REPORTING RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
CABINET LEVEL ADMINISTRATOR
THUS PROVIDING A STRONG AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY ACCOUNTABLE
ADVOCATE TO SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND A ONE DOLLAR DIRECTION FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES TO INTERSTATE
OPERATIONS. THE MILKEN
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS A
THINK TANK BASED HERE WITH
THIRTY THREE YEAR THREE DECADES
SORRY OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN THIS AREA RESEARCH A POLICY
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND WE
STAND BY YOU READY TO ASSIST IN
ANY WAY WE CAN. BUT WE BELIEVE
THESE THREE RECOMMENDATIONS
WHICH IS LOW HANGING FRUIT IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATELY AND CAN
BE ABLE IMPLEMENTED AT THE
AGENCY LEVEL LEVEL EVEN WITHOUT
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CORNELIUS I WILL- JUST HOLD
QUESTIONS UNTIL WE CONCLUDE
WITH EACH OF OUR SPEAKERS. OUR
NEXT SPEAKER IS NANCY SWIFT WHO
IS THE FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF
JEFFERSON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INSTITUTE A PARTNER PROGRAM
WHICH IS CELEBRATING ITS TWENTY
FOURTH YEAR AND SERVING RURAL
ENTREPRENEURS IN THE FAR NORTH
OF CALIFORNIA MISS WEST ALSO
SERVES AS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTER NETWORK. OVER HER THIRTY
YEAR CAREER MISS SWIFT HAS
DEVELOPED A KEEN INTEREST IN
WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS AND HAS
COMMITTED MUCH OF HER
PROFESSIONAL LIFE TO ADVANCING
WOMEN'S ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
MISSED WIFE PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU. I
GUESS THE SOUND WAS LOST ON
THIS PART OF THE VIDEO THIS IS
AN EVENT WE HELD LAST OCTOBER
AND IT ALWAYS BRINGS ME JOY TO
SEE THE FACES OF THE BRAVE
WOMEN WHO ARE NEVER DAUNTED BY
ANY CHALLENGE. IT'S NOT IT'S
ONLY ONE MINUTE DON'T WORRY.
BRINGS THE FACES INTO OUR
HEARING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU TO BOTH CHAIRWOMAN
PETRIE NORRIS AND CERVANTES FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN SHOWCASING
THE IMPORTANCE OF TALKING ABOUT
WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES AS IT RELATES TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY THE
VERY BUSINESSES THAT USE SO-
ARTICULATELY DISCUSS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE PANDEMIC ECONOMY. I AM
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY AND
DISCUSSING WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN DO TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THEM- AS MENTIONED BEFORE- MY
HOME AND MY ROOTS ARE UP IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE
WHICH AS YOU KNOW IS VERY
SMOKY. RIGHT NOW. AND I'M ALSO
CHAIR I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING AND- AS THE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTER NETWORK AND SO I'M HERE
TODAY. REPRESENTING THOSE MANY
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AFFECTED
BY THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. I'M
PLEASED TO SHARE. THE WORK OF
OUR NETWORK WHY WE BELIEVE
WOMEN ARE KEY DRIVERS IN THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. AND WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO SUPPORT
WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
THE NETWORK IS DEDICATED TO
SECURING ECONOMIC EQUITY AN
ENTREPRENEURIAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WOMEN BY FOSTERING
COLLABORATION AND GENERATING
RESOURCES TO BUILD THE CAPACITY
OF ITS MEMBERS. WE ARE SIXTEEN
CENTER STRONG BASE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND DESIGNATED BY
THE US SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION WE PROVIDE SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CAPITAL AN
ACCESS TO MARKETS SERVICES IN
FOURTEEN LANGUAGES SPECIFICALLY
TO UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS INCLUDING WOMEN
MINORITIES. RURAL PEOPLE IN
RURAL AREAS LOW INCOME FOLKS
VETERANS AND THOSE IMPACTED BY
DISASTERS. YOU SAW THAT SHORT
VIDEO OF OUR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SUCCESSES IN RAMPING
UP TO SERVE SO MANY WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURS. WE CONSIDERED
OURSELVES QUOTE ON QUOTE FIRST
RESPONDERS AFTER MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOR WOMEN OWNED
SMALL BUSINESSES WE ARE
PARTNERS WITH L'INDUSTRIE AND
MANAGING A PORTAL OF OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND APPLICATIONS
TO THE CALIFORNIA RELIEF GRANT.
IN TWENTY TWENTY WE SERVED OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT WAS
UP 56% AND WE STARTED AND
SUSTAINED OVER NINE THOUSAND
JOBS  BUSINESSES THAT WAS UP A
HUNDRED AND 50% LEVERAGED OVER
FIFTY MILLION IN GRANTS AND
LOANS. UP A HUNDRED AND 20%
FROM THE YEAR BEFORE AND THAT
IS TO UNDERSERVED BUSINESSES.
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR PROFILE
STATEWIDE. SEVENTY SEVEN. FROM
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND 57%
ARE BUSINESS OWNERS OF COLOR.
YOU CAN SEE THAT OUR NETWORK
MEMBERS ARE MOST ARE SERVING
THE MOST VULNERABLE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT THE STATE IS
INTERESTED IN SUPPORTING BETTER.
WOMEN SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
KEY DRIVERS IN THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY OF CALIFORNIA THEY
MAKE UP THE MAJORITY OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND MICRO
BUSINESS OWNERS AND IN
PARTICULAR WOMEN OF COLOR ARE
GENERATING NEW START UPS AT
FASTER RATES THAN THEIR WHITE-MALE COUNTERPARTS. THROUGH THIS
DOWNTURN WOMEN WERE MORE LIKELY
AS WAS STATED EARLIER. TO BE AN
INDUSTRY'S MOST AFFECTED MOST
LIKELY TO HAVE HAD WAITED YOU
IMPLEMENT SUPPLEMENTING THEIR
HOUSEHOLD INCOME. MOST LIKELY
TO BE MANAGING A HOUSEHOLD AND
THEIR FAMILY NEEDS. MOST LIKELY
TO HAVE LOST THEIR CHILD CARE
OPTIONS. MOST LIKELY WITH A NO
SAVINGS OR ACCESS TO THE
FINANCING THEY NEEDED TO RAMP
UP THEIR SELF EMPLOYMENT
ACTIVITY DURING THIS TIME. THE
COMPOUND EFFECT OF THE PANDEMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES HAS CLEARLY HIT
WOMEN OF COLOR THE HARDEST. SO
WHY ARE THE DRIVERS IN THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WHEN ONE IN
FOUR WOMEN RELY SOLELY ON THEIR
BUSINESS HOUSEHOLD INCOME. AND
THREE AND FOUR RELY AT ON AT
LEAST HALF THEIR INCOME TO COME
FROM THE BUSINESS WE MUST
UNDERSTAND THESE BUSINESSES AND
HOW TO SUPPORT THEM BETTER AND
WHAT THE IMPACT OF THE LOSS OF
BUSINESS REVENUE HAS ON THEIR
HOUSEHOLD INCOME. THIS WILL
HELP US BETTER INVEST IN
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SUPPORTING
FAMILIES AND HELPING CALIFORNIA
RECOVER. AS A NETWORK WHAT WE
IDENTIFY AS CHALLENGES. WE KNOW
THAT CAPITALALONE GENERATES
SOME IMPACT. WHEN COUPLED WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OR TA FOR
SHORT THE IMPACT IS FAR GREATER
AND LONGER SUSTAINED WHEN SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS FACE SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS THAT KEEP THEM FROM
ACCESSING THE CAPITAL AND THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED THEY HAVE FEW
MENTORS AND ARE OFTEN FEELING
ISOLATED. IN ADDITION. AND VERY
RELEVANT TODAY THE LOSS OF THE
COLLECTIVE TWENTY NINE MILLION
IN KERR'S ACT FUNDING THAT MY
COLLEAGUE REFERRED TO EARLIER.
THAT HAS ALLOWED THE STATE'S
NETWORK OF SMALL BUSINESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT WERE
FUNDED THROUGH THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EXPANSION PROGRAM.
TO REACH INCREASED NUMBERS OF
VULNERABLE BUSINESSES THIS LOSS
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THEIR
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF WOMEN.
ALREADY SEEKING SERVICES TODAY.
THIS IS A MOMENT TO BE REACHING
OUT NOT PULLING BACK. AS POLICY
MAKERS WHAT CAN YOU DO TODAY TO
SUPPORT THESE WOMEN SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. THE STATE HAS
TO STRONG ASSETS ROOTED IN
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED TO BE.
ENHANCED AND EXPANDED. THE
CERTIFIED DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND THE SMALL
BUSINESS CENTERS SUCH AS THE
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER AT THE PROCUREMENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
THE MINORITY BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES AND
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS ARE
EACH CREATIVELY SERVING THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITY NEEDS WELL. AND
AT CAPACITY. THE TV PROVIDERS
ARE SO DIVERSE AND SOMETIMES
HARD TO UNDERSTAND COLLECTIVELY
YET IT IS THE DIVERSITY OF
APPROACH AND COMMUNITY AND IN
LANGUAGE SERVICES THAT WILL
UNLEASH THE SUCCESS OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE BUSINESS OWNERS
WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES. STRUCTURE IS IN
PLACE YET IS IN SOME DANGER OF
SHRINKING INSTEAD OF EXPANDING
AT THIS MOMENT. SO LEGISLATORS
CAN CONSIDER A FEW THINGS- FROM
THE NETWORK'S PERSPECTIVE IN
SUPPORT OF THESE ASSETS- WE
ASKED NUMBER ONE THAT THEY THAT
YOU STILL LOOK FOR FUNDS TO
DOUBLE THE S. B. TAPE CURRENT
AMOUNT IN THE BUDGET. ALSO TO
ESTABLISH A RESEARCH ARM THAT
LOOKS AT THE IMPACT OF A SMALL
BUSINESS RUN BY A WOMAN. ON THE
HOUSEHOLD INCOME AND THE FAMILY
WEALTH CREATION THAT KIND OF
RESEARCH WILL HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE RULES THE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE PLAYING IN
HELPING PEOPLE. GROW AND THRIVE.
WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE THE KEY
DRIVERS IN THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY OF THE STATE. THESE
VULNERABLE BUSINESSES MAY BE
SMALL IN SIZE BUT THEY ARE
MIGHTY IN THEIR ECONOMIC ROLE
AND THEIR POTENTIAL TO HELP US
RECOVER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU MISS WHERE
AGAIN WE WILL HOLD QUESTIONS
UNTIL THE END OF OUR THIRD
PANELIST ARTHUR PENALISES
PATPONG PUSHY GUY WHO HAS
SERVED AS A PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE SACRAMENTO ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. AND AS A
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I WHICH SHE
HELPED FORM INTO TWENTY TEN.
MISSED FONG KUSHIDA IS
RECOGNIZED AS AN
ENTREPRENEURIAL LEADER DUE TO
HER SKILLS AND FORMING
COLLABORATIONS AMONG COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND IN
HELPING TO BUILD BUILD PROGRAMS
LIKE THE SACRAMENTO EXPORTS.
THAT SERVES OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND ASIAN PACIFIC ON
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE AS WELL
AS THE BROADER MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESS COMMUNITY MISS FONG
KUSHIDA PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN MADAM CHAIR CERVANTES AND
PETRIE-NORRIS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO BE SURE TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. AS CHAIR
SERVE OUR SAID WE DO. THE
INTERESTS OF OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND. API OWN BUSINESSES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO
OPERATE A SERIES OF FEDERAL AND
STATE SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. CENTERS AND LOCAL
PROGRAMS THAT DELIVER DIRECT
SERVICES TO WOMEN. AND MINORITY
OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY THE UNDERSERVED. AND
WE ARE HONORED TO BE HAVE BEEN
INVITED TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
FOR YOU HERE TODAY. IS YOU
KNOW. WE ARE NOW A MAJORITY
MINORITY STATE. 63% A MINORITY
36% IDENTIFY AS WHITE. AND IT
IS WELL KNOWN THE CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO THE LARGEST SHARE OF
MINORITY BUSINESS ENTERPRISES
IN AMERICA SURPASSING ALL OTHER
STATES HOWEVER WHAT IS LESS
UNDERSTOOD ABOUT THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF KOBE
NINETEEN IS THAT THE IMPACT OF
ITS EFFECTS FELT AND CONTINUE
TO FALL HARDEST ON WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED SMALL
BUSINESSES. WHO ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH CULTURAL AND
LANGUAGE BARRIERS DIFFICULT IN
ACCESSING CAPITAL AND
GOVERNMENT AND COMMERCIAL
SYSTEMS THAT BLOCK THEIR
ABILITY TO COMPETE ON EQUAL
FOOTING ADDITIONALLY A
SIGNIFICANT RISE OF HATE CRIMES
HAS ONLY MADE CONDITIONS WORSE
FOR MINORITY EMPLOYERS SIMPLY
TRYING TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN.
AS CHAIR CERVANTES HIGHLIGHTED
IN OPENING REMARKS AND DESPAIR
IS WORTH REPEATING. WE NEED TO
THE NATIONALBUREAU OF ECONOMIC
RESEARCH BETWEEN FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY THE NUMBER OF ACTIVE
BLACK OWNED BUSINESSES DECLINED
41% LAND NEXT OWN BUSINESSES
DECLINED 32% AN ASIAN OWNED
BUSINESSES DROPPED 25% VERSUS
THE 21% FOR THE GENERAL
POPULATION OVERALL. SATTAR'S
WHERE MINORITY BUSINESSES ARE
CONCENTRATED LIKE RETAIL
HOSPITALITY AND ENTERTAINMENT
WOULD ESPECIALLY HIT HARD. WHAT
WE MUST KEEP IN MIND IS THAT
WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING PRE CLOVIS THE
PANDEMIC AND ECONOMIC
CATASTROPHE IT BECAUSE SIMPLY
MAKE THINGS DRAMATICALLY WORSE
AND EXPOSE STARK INEQUITIES FOR
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES.
ACCESS TO CAPITAL HAS LONG BEEN
A HUGE BARRIER TO MINORITY
BUSINESS SUCCESS A RECENT
BROOKINGS INSTITUTE STUDY FOUND
THAT LARGE BANKS APPROVE ABOUT
60% OF LOANS FOR WHITE BUSINESS
OWNERS. 50% OF THOSE NON STOP
BY HISPANIC AND LATIN THAT'S
BUSINESS OWNERS BUT JUST 29%
SOUGHT BY BLACK BUSINESS OWNERS.
FEDERAL RESERVE BANKS HAVE
REPORTED FOR OVER A DECADE THAT
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO
SHOW SIGNS OF LIMITED FINANCIAL
HEALTH. BY FACTORS SUCH AS
PROFITABILITY CREDIT SCORES.
AND THE PROPENSITY TO USE
RETAINED EARNINGS DOES THEIR
PRIMARY FUNDING SOURCE. THESE
BUSINESSES WERE TWICE AS LIKELY
TO BE CLASSIFIED AS- AS AT RISK
WERE DISTRESSED THEN NON
MINORITY BUSINESS. OWNERS IF
YOU CONSIDER LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTIONS FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
CANNOT STRESS HOW IMPORTANT
WRAPAROUND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SERVICES ARE TO SERVICE SMALL
BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
ASSIST BUSINESS OWNERS
REGARDLESS OF CITIZENSHIP AND
IMMIGRATION STATUS IN ACCESSING
CAPITAL REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
PROCUREMENT BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS MATCH MAKING AND SO
MUCH MORE. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
AND IS MY COLLEAGUES WHO STATED
THE SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EXPANSION PROGRAM SB
TAPE HAS PROVEN. I'M GONNA SAY
THIS AGAIN HAS PROVEN TO BE A
LIFELINE OF CRITICAL SUPPORT
SERVICES. AND IT IS NOW UNDER
FUNDED. AND THE STATE. I WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO RUSSIA
THE CALIFORNIA RELIEF GRANTED-THE DREAM FUND WITHOUT THE
STATE WIDE NETWORK OF SB EIGHT
TAKE FROM FIGHTERS SB TABLE
SUNSET. IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AND WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE ACTION
THE EXPANDED SUPPORT SERVICES
TO ALL SMALL BUSINESSES WILL
ALSO SEND SET AT THIS TIME. NOT
ONLY SHOULD SB TAPE BE RENEWED
BUT THE FUNDING SHOULD BE
INCREASED TO REFLECT NOT ONLY
THE CONTINUED GRWING NEEDS OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SERVICES.
BUT THE EXPANDED POOL OF
NETWORK PROVIDERS SINCE TAPES
INCEPTION. PROCUREMENT WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES YOU ARE THE LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN THE LARGEST
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA PERIOD. AND THAT
IS WHY CAL ASIAN ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC IN
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
COSPONSORED AB NINE FIFTEEN.
WHICH SOME OF YOU HAVE
GRACIOUSLY CO AUTHORED AND WE
WANT TO THANK YOU ESPECIALLY
CHAIR PETRIE-NORRIS A MEMBER
GARCIA. EIGHTY NINE FIFTEEN
WILL CODIFY THE STATE'S 25%
SMALL BUSINESS PROCUREMENT GOAL
WHICH BEGAN AS AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER FROM THE SCHWARZENEGGER
ADMINISTRATION BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX. NOW WHILE WE
KNOW THERE ARE CHALLENGES IN
ACCESSING STATE CONTRACTS
ESPECIALLY FOR MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES AB NINE FIFTEEN IS
THE RIGHT SOLUTION AT THE RIGHT
TIME AND WITH HIS PASSAGE WE
HOPE IT WILL BE THE FIRST. IN
MANY STEPS TO PROVIDE MARKET
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL
BUSINESS GROWTH. FINALLY YOUR
COMMITTEE SHOULD CONSIDER
SOLUTIONS FOR THOUGHTFUL
REGULATORY MODERN TRANSLATION.
AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY
REDUNDANCIES THROUGHOUT THE
BUREAUCRACY OUR SYSTEMATIC
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS TO SMALL
BUSINESS SUCCESS REGARDLESS OF
GENDER AND ETHNICITY. ACCESS IS
A FORM OF EQUITY AND THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO BE VERY
SERIOUS AND INTENTIONAL AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY HONESTLY
EVALUATE WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN'T WITHIN OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS. CONSIDER
WORKING WITH PARTNERS SUCH AS
S. HERE TODAY THE TAKE NETWORK
AND OTHERS TO CREATE
LEGISLATION THAT MODERNIZES ARE
COMPLICATED REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT. IN A MEANINGFUL
AND EQUITABLE WAY. THIS
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION AND
THANK YOU AGAIN. FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ALL TODAY. THANK YOU MISS
PARKER SHE THAT WE DO HAVE A
FEW MOMENTS AFTER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP. WITH
THE QUESTION OF MY OWN WE ARE
HEARD FROM EACH OF OUR-PANELISTS ACCESS TO CAPITAL-
AND AS WAS JUST MENTIONED WHICH
IS A FORM OF EQUITY WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES. DO ANY OF YOU HAVE
KEY RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO WHAT
ACTIONS EITHER THE LEGISLATURE
OR THE ADMINISTRATION CAN TAKE
TO REALLY MITIGATE THE
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS AMONG THE
DIFFERENT BUSINESS GROUPS. YES
YES I THINK THAT WOULD. IN MY
FIRST RECOMMENDATION WE TALKED
ABOUT COLLECTING DATA. THE
MAPPING OF CAPITAL FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES IS KEY BECAUSE IT
WILL CREATE A DATABASE OF
AVAILABLE FUNDS WHOSE FUNDING
WHAT KINDS OF BUSINESSES WHAT
KINDS OF FIRMS. WHAT SIZE OF
FIRMS. WHO WHERE ARE THEY ARE
THEY THE ONES IF CALLS ARE THEY
IN WHICH DAY IS THE BEST THING
TO GO TO THIS DATABASE IS
MAINTAINED BY THE BY THE- THE
GOVERNMENT OR BY A THIRD PARTY
IF THE GOVERNMENT. CHOOSES TO
CONTRACTED OUT WOULD. BE
AVAILABLE TWENTY FOUR HOURS
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THEY WILL NOT
HAVE TO GO FROM BANK TO BANK TO
BANK TO BANK TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT IS NEEDED OR WHO WILL BE
THING IS THAT IT WOULD DO IS IT
WOULD TIE IN TO WHAT YOU HEARD
BY MY TWO OTHER COLLEAGUES
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. IF WE
DON'T GIVE THE SMALL
BUSINESSES. A CENTRAL POINT. TO
GO IF WE DON'T FIND AND EXPAND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BEEN
AVAILABLE COMMUNITIES WITH
CULTURALLY. SENSITIVE OF. B.
HEY. PATTERNS IN IT THEN WE ARE
TO LOSE THEM AT THE GATE. AND
WE HAVE THAT BEAUTIFUL NETWORK
WITHIN CALIFORNIA AS YOU HEAR
FROM MY TWO COLLEAGUES STILL
SUPPORTING THAT AND GVING THEM
THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WITH
AN WITH A WEB BASED. HERE'S
WHERE THE LENDERS ARE HERE IS
WHAT THE LENDERS ARE FINDING.
THIS IS WHERE THEY ARE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY. THAT WILL GET OVER
THE LACK OF CONTACT AND IN
RELATIONSHIPS THAT. MINORITIES
AND WOMEN DIDN'T HAVE WHICH LED
TO THEM NOT BE APPROVED M. S.
N. ACCEPTED IN THE PAST. IF I
COULD COMMENT. THE NETWORK OF
CDFI HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IS
ACTUALLY DOING GOD'S WORK THESE
ARE THE RETURN OF LENDERS THAT
MANY OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES-
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY ACCESS
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR FOLKS DON'T
QUALIFY FOR TRADITIONAL
LENDING. I THINK THE CITY OF
FIVE OR SUCH AN IMPORTANT PART.
OF ACCESS TO CAPITAL THEY NEED
TO BE FULLY FUNDED THEY NEED TO
HAVE THE KIND OF SUPPORT FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BECAUSE A
LOT OF THESE FOLKS TO GO THERE
NEED TO TYPE IT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO QUALIFY BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
THE STATE GUARANTEE PROGRAM
WHERE THE STATE GUARANTEES A
PORTION. OF THE LOAN SHE GUYS
HAVE GOT TO STREAMLINED
APPLICATION PROCESS YOU JUST
HAVE TO AND I DON'T KNOW- WE
USED TO RUN A PEER TO PEER
LENDING PROGRAM AND IT WAS A
STATE GUARANTEE PROGRAM WE WORK
THROUGH THE CDFI. THE PAPERWORK
IN THE AMOUNT OF- OVERSIGHT
REQUIRED ON THESE LOANS. VERY
VERY DIFFICULT FOR MINORITY
SMALL BUSINESS TO NAVIGATE
THROUGH SO I WOULD TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT. PROGRAM STRAIGHTEN IT
AND STREAMLINING. IF I MAY- I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
SOMETHING ELSE I THINK WE COULD
DO HERE THERE WE HAVE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED SOMEWHAT IN IN.
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S RISK
MITIGATION CREDIT ENHANCEMENTS
SUCH AS A GUARANTEED PROGRAM
FROM THE STATE TREASURY OFFICE-
CALIFORNIA CAPITAL ACCESS
PROGRAM- AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ECONOMIC. THANK OR I THINK.
THE SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAMS THROUGH THE
TA PROVIDERS THAT COULD NOT
PROVIDE SUPPORT ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE THINGS THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE THAT WE CAN USE.
AND WE CAN ENHANCE AND WE CAN
BUILD ON MAKING ACCESS TO
CAPITAL MORE FAVORABLE TO WOMEN
AND MINORITIES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SAY EACH OF OUR PANELISTS
I WOULD LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO
ANY QUESTIONS MAYBE MEMBERS.
SURE PETRIE-NORRIS AS WELL
THANK YOU AGAIN SO MUCH FOR-
FOR BEING HERE AND PROJECT
PARTICULARLY FOR THE CONCRETE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU HAVE
THAT HAVE SHARED WITH US I JUST
WANNA. DIVE INTO A COUPLE OF
OTHERS SO- MS WEST AND MISS
FONG CAN SHE GET YOU BOTH
TALKED ABOUT AT. THE IMPORTANCE
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND-
THE NEED TO EXPAND THE S. B.
TAKE PROGRAM- I THINK IS MISTER
TO YOUR RECOMMENDATION IS THAT.
WE SHOULD DOUBLE THE PROGRAM'S
COMING YEAR TO THIRTY FOUR
MILLION- SIX TWO QUESTIONS ONE
FOR. JUST YOU FIVE RESPOND
BECAUSE SHE THAT WOULD THAT BE
SIMILAR TO THE TARGET NUMBER
YOU'D HAVE IN MIND- AND THEN
SECOND FOR BOTH OF YOU CAN YOU
HELP US UNDERSTAND. WHAT WITH
THOSE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES MEAN
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE AND AT
THE NUMBER OF WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES. THAT
ARE ABLE TO BE SUPPORTIVE. YOU
RECEIVED A LETTER THAT WAS
DATED JULY FOURTEENTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR ONE. AND IT WAS
ADDRESSED TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- AND I THINK IN THAT
LETTER THERE WERE VERY
SPECIFIC- METRICS IN TERMS OF
THE FUNDING. NOW THAT
PARTICULAR LETTER WAS FOCUSED
ON. INCREASED TO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE DREAM ACT
ABOUT SEVEN MILLION. BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ATTACHED TO THE
DREAM ACT- PROGRAM MY DAY WAS
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD BUT NO
DIRECT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NOW
THINK ABOUT THIS FOR JUST A
SECOND IF YOU'VE GOT CURRENT
TATE PROVIDERS IN IN IN THE
CURRENT ITERATION- TAPE WOULD
ONLY BE ABLE TO BE. ACCESSED
BY- FOLKS THAT ALREADY RAN
FEDERAL CENTERS IT WAS A
MATCHING PROGRAM. THIS YEAR-
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS OPENED
UP TAPE TO OTHER SERVICE
PROVIDERS NON FEDERAL CENTERS
WHICH- WHICH IS I THINK GOING
TO ENHANCE THE PROGRAM BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S YOU KNOW IS VERY
BIG AND DIVERSE AND THERE ARE
THAT PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. BESIDES THE
FEDERALLY FUNDED CENTERS BUT
THEN THINK ABOUT THAT FOR
SECOND GOT SEVENTEEN MILLION
THAT WILL GOING JUST TO THE
FEDERALLY FUNDED CENTERS AND
NOW YOU'VE EXPANDED THE PROGRAM
BEYOND JUST. THE FOR THE
FEDERALLY FUNDED CENTERS. BUT
WITH NO ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
COMBAT SO I'M IN AGREEMENT WITH
MY COLLEAGUES I MEAN I DO THINK
THAT IT NEEDS TO BE FUNDED AND
MADE A WHOLE. IS SEVENTEEN
MILLION THE RIGHT NUMBER I
WOULD DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE BUT
I'M IN SUPPORT. OF THAT NUMBER.
THANK YOU OF. IF WHAT WOULD
THAT MEAN- ACTUALLY MY COMMENT
WAS TO LOOK FOR THAT MONEY THIS
TERM IF THERE'S ANY LAST DITCH
EFFORT. IF THERE IS ONE OF THE
LETTERS THAT UP. THAT WAS
REFERRING TO DOCUMENTS THAT THE
COST PER BUSINESS SERVICE
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS SO
YOU CAN DO THE MATH TO SEE HOW
MANY BUSINESSES. WOULD BE
SERVED AND IT IS ADMIRABLE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EXPAND THE POT OF.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
THAT'S A VERY BOLD AND
IMPORTANT MOVE WE NEED ALL
HANDS ON DECK RIGHT NOW. AND IF
WE DOUBLE THE FUNDING THAT WAS
THAT WOULD BE LEVERAGING. ALL
THE FEDERALLY DESIGNATED
CENTERS. THEY'RE BASICALLY
MATCHING THAT MONEY THEY'RE
GETTING FROM THE STATE AND THEN
THE ADDITIONAL CENTERS ARE ALSO
PROVIDING MATCH SO WE'RE
LEVERAGING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
WE ARE INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
OUT THERE SUPPORTING THIS VERY
CREATIVE ACCESS TO CAPITAL AT A
VERY LOW COST. IN VERY HIGH
TOUCH SERVICES SO- I DON'T HAVE
AN EXACT NUMBER BUSINESSES THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THAT BUT YOU
COULD SEE THAT ALL HANDS ON
DECK RIGHT NOW ALL OF US ARE
RECEIVING CALLS AND WE'RE NOT
SURE HOW TO KEEP UP WITH THEM-
WE HAVE PLEDGES TO RETURN A
CALL TO SOMEBODY IN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AND TO SERVE THEM WITHIN
SEVEN DAYS AND JUST IMAGINE
THAT AS MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
ARE LEARNING ABOUT US WHICH HAS
BEEN TRUE- THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA RELIEF GRANT. PEOPLE
SAID I HAD NO IDEA THERE WAS A
NETWORK OUT HERE THAT CARE
ABOUT ME WELL LET'S EXPAND THAT
NOW. THANK YOU. IT CERTAINLY IT
CERTAINLY SEEMS LIKE- AN
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT WITH HUGE
RETURNS ON OFFER FOR THE STATE
FARM CENTER. WILL BE WORKING
WITH I THINK A NUMBER OF THE
FOLKS HERE TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
PUSH THAT FORWARD. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ARE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO ASK
QUESTION OF- MISTER CORNELIUS
BELIEVED EARLIER YOU MENTIONED
THAT ONE OF THE LOW HANGING
FRUIT SOLUTIONS- IS TO REFINE
PART OF THE UNUSED RESEARCH
CREDITS- SO I WAS WONDERING IF
YOU COULD ELABORATE ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT SO HOW WOULD THAT
WORK IN REALITY I MEAN. SINCE
SINCE THE- THE CREDITS ARE
ACTUALLY UNUSED LET'S SEE BY
START UPS OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE OFF HOW WOULD. YOU KNOW
THAT CREDIT BE ALLOCATED TO
THAT THE OTHER START OBSERVE.
OR YOU KNOW OTHER PEOPLE. SO
YOU YOU COULD TAKE THE HONEST.
OF THE ARE AN INTAKE YOU FOR
THE QUESTION I THINK THERE'S A
EXCELLENT QUESTION TO ASK. YOU
COULD TAKE A PORTION OF THE
ARGUES. RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDIT AND
PROVIDE GRANTS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THEIR RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT PRODUCT WHICH
THEY DON'T HAVE. AND THAT COULD
GENERATE NEW REVENUES FROM THE
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION- THAT FIRMS THAT
ARE THERE. SO WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IS YOU'RE TAKING. MONEY THAT IS
ALREADY SET ASIDE A GREAT IS
THAT ARE NOT BEING USED AND
YOUR REAPPLYING THEM THROUGH A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO TECHNICALLY
WOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
GROUP BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
REVENUE. OR THEIR START OUT BUT
THEY HAVE THE POTENTIAL OF
MAKING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY IT REVENUES IF THEIR
PRODUCT IS BROUGHT TO
COMMERCIALIZATION. SO THAT'S
WHAT YOU WOULD DO YOU WOULD
TAKE THAT UNFORTUNATE PART MAKE
IT INTO A GRANT TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESS GIVE IT TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS OR EVEN EVEN A LOW
INTEREST LOANS. TO SMALL
BUSINESS FOUR RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT THAT THEY NORMALLY
WOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO. SO
THEN THERE'S ALREADY A POT OF
MONEY OUT THERE THAT WE COULD
TAP INTO AND IF SO HOW MUCH
WITHOUT DOUBT IS NOT PART OF
MONEY. I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY THE
AMOUNT OF THE POT OF MONEY BUT
THERE IS A GREAT NUMBER A GOOD
PERCENTAGE DOLLAR OF THE R. D.
TAX CREDIT THAT IS THAT GOES
UNUSED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SIENET NO QUESTIONS FROM ME
MEMBERS I JUST WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK EACH OF OUR
SPEAKERS TODAY FOR THEIR TIME
IN THE- EXPRESS. THAT OR
COMMITTEES GRATITUDE FOR YOUR
INSIGHTS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATIONS. THANK YOU. I
DON'T KNOW IF OUR NEXT SPEAKER
WILL. COME TO THE PRESENTATION
TABLE I'LL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF OUR NEXT AGENDA
ITEM. AT THROUGHOUT THE PAST
YEAR CALIFORNIA HAS ROLLED OUT
A NUMBER OF CRITICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
ARE THE FEEDBACK WE'VE HEARD
TIME AND AGAIN AND IT WAS
ECHOED EVEN IN NOT IN OUR MOST
RECENT CONVERSATION. IS THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRUSTED COMMUNITY
PARTNERS THIS IS ESPECIALLY KEY
FOR WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES. I HAVE A SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS TO SUCCESS AND OFTEN
LACK TRADITIONAL. ACCESS TO
CRITICAL FUNDING SOURCES. LOCAL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS
HAVE SERVED A VITAL SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL AS WE SEEK EVERITT
BASKIN EQUITABLE RECOVERY.
WE'VE ASKED OUR NEXT SPEAKER
CARMEN HERRERA MEN'S HERE TO
SHARE HER EXPERIENCE AND
EXPERTISE WITH US TODAY MS
HERRERA MAN SEER IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT AL HARO
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. IN WATSONVILLE
CALIFORNIA THE GRANDDAUGHTER OF
BRACERO FARMWORKERS AND THE
DAUGHTER OF A FARM WORKER
TURNED SUCCESSFUL ENTREPRENEUR.
HER FAMILY HISTORY PROVIDES HER
WITH A POWERFUL PERSPECTIVE AND
MOTIVATION TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE BROADER
ECONOMIC INCLUSION OF
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND
UNDER HER LEADERSHIP ALL HER OF
CDC HAS FURTHER THAT CAUSE BY
OFFERING ENTREPRENEURS TO
BUSINESS INCUBATION SPACES AS
WELL AS COMPREHENSIVE SMALL
BUSINESS EDUCATION AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. MISERERE
AMOUNTS HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING. US ON THE FLOOR
SHARKS. THANK YOU- INTEREST
PLACE I WANNA THINK- ASSEMBLY
WOMEN'S SABRINA CERVANTES THEN
ASSEMBLY WOMEN AT THREE- FOR
YOUR LEADER CHIEF AND FOR- YOU
KNOW HAVING THIS CONVERSATION%
ABOUT THE RECOVERY FOR WOMEN
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES-
I HOPE THAT AT THE END OF THE-
THESE EVENTS THAT WE WILL LEAVE
WITH A COMMON UNDERSTANDING OF
THE NEEDS OF BUSINESS SAYS AND
PERHAPS AT LEAST IN OUR MINDS I
PLAN. TO ENSURE THEIR RECOVERY
AND SUCCESS- MOVING FORWARD. I
WANT TO INVITE IT TO PREPARE
ADD 2% OF A I'M OUT HOW
ORGANIZATION- WORK AND- HAS
BEEN ABLE TO IMPACT- THE
COMMUNITY OF BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN. YOU KNOW SUFFERING
THAT COVERT NINETEEN TRACK TRY
TO THE- AND I'M NOT BEING
DRAMATIC- THIS IS HOW IT FEELS.
WHEN A BUSINESS OWNER HE LOSES
EVERYTHING AND IS THERE-
LIVELIHOOD- AND DO THEY HAVE I
WANT TO START BY TEARING IN A-
A STORY. AND I WENT TO VISIT TO
IRAQ AND YOUR SEEN ONLINE. T.
THE ON OF A THIRTY OLD BUSINESS-
THEY SELF SEED. AND THE
EMPLOYEES SEVEN PEOPLE LINKED
WITHIN THEMSELVES THAT HUSBAND
AND THE WIFE- ABOUT A MONTH
AFTER ME I. YOU KNOW WE THE
CLOSURE HAPPEN AND- AND WE
STARTED. PROVIDING SERVICES-
AND HELPING PEOPLE AND I AND
ABOUT A MONTH AGO AFTER THEY
HAD RECEIVED THE FIRST B. B. B.
LOAN I WENT THERE AND- MOVED TO
BUY LUNCH AND THEY THEY
WOULDN'T CHARGE ME. MESSAGES
JACKSON. IN IN SHE SAID WHAT I
HAVE THERE THE QUOTE WITH. IF
IT WEREN'T FOR YOU. WE WERE IN
BE HERE. I'M SORRY. IT IN. I
THINK THAT SUMS IT UP. YOU KNOW
ALARA BUSINESSES- THAT HAD BEEN
ABLE TO RECEIVE SERVICES. WOULD
HAVE DISAPPEAR IF IT WASN'T
BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT OF
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS- WHEN I
WENT THERE THE FIRST TIME. THE
VIOLENCE- A THEY DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE OUT THERE I ASKED
HOWARD THAT THEY WERE DOING AND
THEY SAID THEY- LOST IN HOUR
MONEY BECAUSE- WHEN THE
PANDEMIC STARTED. THEY HAD
ALREADY BOUGHT ALL THEIR
SEAFOOD FOR THE LENT SEASON
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT HANNAH
COMMUNITY LIKE OURS- IN. AND
IT'S ALSO FOR THEM THE START OF
THEIR- OTHER HIGH SEASON A
BUSINESS IN. I ASKED YOU KNOW
THERE'S HELP INTO THAT NEW I
DON'T KNOW I AM. D. WAS LIKE
SUPER OVERWHELM AND YOU KNOW I
SAID OKAY- WE'RE GOING TO HELP
YOU- LONG STORY SHORT AFTER OUR
STAFF WORKING WITH THEM VERY
HARD. FIRST WE HELP THEM I'M.
AND GET THE FIRST B. B. B. THEN
THEY GOT ACCESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED GRANT AND
THEN THEY GOT ACCESS TO I THE
SECOND PPP AND AT THIS POINT
THEY HAVE RECEIVE FORGIVENESS
FOR BOTH OF THE PPP'S. BATTLE
OF DAYS WAS ONLY POSSIBLE-
BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO YOU
KNOW. HAVE A TEAM OF PEOPLE
THAT WERE HELPING THEM AND- AND
EACH STEP OF THE WAY BECAUSE
THE PROCESS FOR. ANYBODY THAT
IS GOING THROUGH. WHAT THEY
WERE GOING IT WAS JUST
OVERWHELMING AND WE HAVE
HUNDREDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT LACK THE BIRD LOVER
LEATHER WE HELP NOT PARALYZE
THE NAME IS THIS- AND SO FAR
WE'VE DONE OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS OF. THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ATTRACT TO OUR
COMMUNITY WHICH IS LARGELY A
COMMUNITY OF FARMWORKERS AND
YOU KNOW WE CAN WE CONTINUE TO
SERVE HIGH VOLUME OF. BUSINESS
SAYS AND WE KNOW THAT WITH THE
NEW FUNDING COMING OUR WAY
THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT MORE
REQUESTS FOR SERVICES- WE KNOW
THAT ON. OUR ARE THERE WOULD BE
A NUMBER OF REQUESTS FOR
SERVICES TRIPLE. AND YOU KNOW
IN AND WE KNOW THAT ONCE. WE
THE PEOPLE START LISTENING MORE
ABOUT THE FUNDING THEY'RE GONNA
CALL US. AND IT TAKES US ABOUT.
ON AVERAGE OF TEN HOURS- TO
SERVE. ONE BUSINESS FOR ONE OF
THE PROGRAMS. SO AND WE HAD TO
INCREASE OUR STAFFING AND WE'RE
ANTICIPATING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO INCREASE THE
STAFFING. AGAIN. IN YOU KNOW
CAN WE MOVE THE SLIDE. THANK
YOU I SO. AND WHAT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH NUMBER LIES NOT
SOMETHING THAT DOES HAPPEN TO
THEM THIS IS HAPPENED TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN. ONE OF THE
REASONS WE ABLE TO HELP THEM IS
BECAUSE- FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
OUR ORGANIZATION HAS WORKED
VERY HARD. TO- BUILD- IN YOU
KNOW OVER TIME A WHAT WE
CONSIDER A THINK A- AN ACRE-
LIKE THAT ENDED THE SYSTEM OF
SERVICES AND RESOURCES FOR
PEOPLE TO HAVE ABOUT TO BE.
ABLE TO YOU KNOW SUCCEED IN
BUSINESS A VERY VERY LARGE
NUMBER OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE OUR ON FARM WORKERS THAT
ARE LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES
THAT OUR ORGANIZATION'S MISSION
IS TO PROMOTE EQUAL ACCESS TO
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. AND IT
WAS FUN THEN HAVING IN MIND.
THE IDEA OF FARM WORKING
FAMILIES BEING ABLE TO START A
BUSINESS THAT WILL HELP THEM
YOU KNOW TO ACHIEVE ECONOMIC
MOBILITY. I'M SO. A. N. OVER
THE YEARS WE'VE DEVELOPED THE
STRATEGY IN AN OUTWARD THAT IS
THE KEY THERE IS ACCESS. AXIS
TO. INFORMATION THE FACT THAT I
WENT THERE AND TALKED TO THE
OWNER THAT SHE KNEW ME EVEN
THOUGH THERE WAS A LOT THERE
WAS A TON OF INFORMATION OUT
THERE IN THE NEWS EVERYWHERE
BUT IT WASN'T UNTIL THE TRUST
THE ESSENGER. CAME AND TALKED
TO HER ABOUT THE PROGRAM IS
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO MOVE
THAT WE ALL OF OUR WORK AS
MUCH. MARKETING WITH THE WITH
THE ALWAYS HAPPENS BECAUSE
SOMEONE COMES TO LAST BECAUSE
OF WORD OF MOUTH. WE WORK WITH
CERTAIN NETWORKS WE HAVE A
NETWORK OF TOP HOW MANY
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS ONCE WE
SERVE TWO OF THEM TWENTY WILL
COME THE NEXT DAY TO REQUEST
SERVICES- ACCESS TO SUPPORTING
SERVICES ACCESS TO SPACE- IN
FOR THESE TWO- FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN. OUR TEAM HAS TO BECOME
AN ALLY. AND WE'RE NOT JUST
PROVIDING THAT BUYS WE BECOME
THEIR MENTORS WE BECOME THEIR
ADVOCATES- WE HAVE TO HANDHOLD
THEM MANY TIMES THROUGH THERE'S
PROVIDING THE SERVICES- A BIG
THING WITH ACCESSING GRANTS AND
THAT KIND OF THINGS IS
SOMETIMES THIS TECHNOLOGY. YOU
KNOW JUST BEING ABLE TO SCAN
THE DOCUMENT BEING ABLE TO KNOW
HOW TO ASK THE BANK FOR THE
RIGHT INFORMATION BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS YOUR. ACCOUNTANT FOR THE
RIGHT INFORMATION. SO THANKS.
OF THE FACT THAT WE HAVE BUILT
THIS PROGRAM- WE CURRENTLY ARE
ABLE TO SERVE AND PROVIDE
BILINGUAL AND ACCESSIBLE
TRAININGS. THE COACHING- WE ARE
ABLE TO DO PROVIDE SPACE FOR
OUR INCUBATORS AND WE ARE ABLE
TO- RESPOND THE WAY THAT WE
WERE THEY HAVE RESPONDED TO THE
STATE. AND- SO I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU THIS. BECAUSE WE WANT THEM.
BE ABLE TO SHARE WITH THE
COMMUNITY WHILE WE'VE DONE AND
BE ABLE TO- TELL YOU. THAT IT
IS WORK WHILE SUPPORTING
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS AND-
THANKS TO COMMUNITY SUPPORT AND
TARNISHES WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BUILD THIS ORGANIZATION NOT CAN
WE MOVE THAT. AND AND OVER THE
YEARS WE'VE BEEN CREATING THOSE
SPACE THIS IS SUPPORTING AND
HER PARTNERS- ONE EXAMPLE ONE
EXAMPLE IS OUR BLESSING HE
RETELLING CURATOR THAT IS
LOCATED IN DOWNTOWN MONTEBELLO-
WE HAVE THEIR SIXTEEN
BUSINESSES SIXTEEN OF THEM ARE
OWNED BY WOMEN. 90% OF THEM
WENT THROUGH OUR IMPRESARIO
PROGRAM WHICH IS A CORE
EDUCATION BUSINESS TO THE
PATIENT PROGRAM THAT WE OFFER
AND THAT NOW WE HAVE TRANSITION
ONLINE AND- WE ARE- ALSO GLAD
THAT HE HAS IS THAT AN ASSET
FOR THE COMMUNITY. WE ARE YOU
THE RESULT IN PEOPLE COME TO US
IS BECAUSE OF THE ALSO OUR
ORGANIZATION IS VERY ENGAGE IN
THE COMMUNITY WE JUST THE FINE
EXAMPLE TWO WEEKS AGO WE HOSTED
A- BAXEEN LANEY- DOING BY THE
CLIENTS OF OUR- ENTERPRENEURS.
AND IT WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE PEOPLE TRUST ALSO YOU
KNOW OUR BUSINESSES- THE OTHER
A BLAZE THEN IS THRIVING NOW
AND IF WE WANT TO MOVE TO THE
NEXT ONE IS THERE A COMMERCIAL
KITCHEN INCUBATOR ASKED IF. YOU
MAY NOW WHERE WE SERVE THE
SENATE IS MODERATE IN SOME ANY
TO COLONIES WHICH IS- I HAVE AN
AREA THAT PRODUCES A LOT OF
FOOD THAT HAS A BIG FOOD
LOCATION. AND THAT HAS A LOT OF
PRODUCTION OF ORGANIC. YOU KNOW.
PRODUCTS AND- SO I IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE WE ARE BUT
THIRTEEN SORRY WE OPENED THIS
COMMUNITY KITCHEN- WE CURRENTLY
SERVE ABOUT THIRTY THIRTY FIVE
BUSINESSES THAT OPERATE THERE
BUT THE PLACE HAS BECOME MORE
OF A- THE- FOOD CLUSTER- ASIDE
FROM HOST POSTING ON FOOD
ENTREPRENEURS- WE ALSO HAVE A-
THE SMALL FARMER THAT-
PRODUCES- THAT IT WAS ABLE TO
CREATE A HIGH I WOULD HAVE. AND
WE'RE CURRENTLY A BUILDING IN A
CALL BACK IN LINE TO DO PROCESS
OF VALUE ADDED PRODUCTS FROM
THE LOCAL SMALL FARMS IF WE CAN
MOVE TO THE NEXT ONE. YEAH SO
IF YOU ALL HAVE THAT
PRESENTATION I CAN'T SEE FROM
HERE BUT IF YOU. THE WE ARE
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE
DEVELOPED THIS- IDEA OF THAT WE
HAVE TO BE. AT CLIENTS CENTER
IN BE ABLE TO PROVIDE ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT SERVICES TO OUR
CLIENTS AND- THERE IS A
STRATEGY. THAT HAS HELP US-
WHAT WE'VE DONE SO FAR IN TERMS
OF HELPING CLIENTS- WE KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED A LOT
MORE SUPPORT. AND BECAUSE IF
THINGS ARE YOU KNOW THE
EMERGENCE IS STILL GOING ON AND
I HOPE THAT BY SHARING THE
STRATEGY THAT WE USE AND-
TELLING YOU HOW PEOPLE CAN COME
AND FEEL COMFORTABLE ACCESSING
THAT OTHER IMPORTANT. WORK THAT
WE DO WE DO IS THAT WE ALSO
TALKED TO A LOT OF RURAL
CLIENTS. AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT. VERY FEW CENTERS ARE
DOING AND THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE RURAL AREAS.
HAD NOT BEEN I HAVE NOT
RECEIVED AS MUCH FUNDING IS
VERY VERY LITTLE FUNDING FROM
PPP OR EVEN THAT CALIFORNIA
RACK THAT HAS GONE THROUGH
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND WE HOPE.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL THINK
ABOUT YOU KNOW HELPING MATH-
GET STRONGER THE SERVER WELL
THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU. HELLO
AND THANK YOU AT SO CLEAR YOU
HAVE PLAYED AN ABSOLUTELY
TRANSFORMATIVE ROLE IN THE
LIVES OF. OF IT THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVE AND-
AND YOU'VE OFFERED SUCH A
CRITICAL LIFELINE PARTICULARLY.
IN THE MIDST OF THE COVERED
CRISIS ATSU WE'VE GOT ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES FOR QUESTIONS IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS. ALRIGHT SEEING AND
HEARING NINE. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT HOW
WE CAN CAN HELP. BUILD AT THE
SUPPORT AND THAT AND BUILD OUT
THIS MODEL ALL ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR
A BIG AND MOVED OUR NEXT PASS.
I DO WANT TO JUST SAY MISS HAD
ADAM ON SAID THANK YOU FOR
SHARING WENT AND BOUGHT A CDC
DOES IN OUR COMMUNITIES SO
INSPIRING AND UPLIFTING AND
CONTINUE THE WONDERFUL WORK HI
THAT YOU ALL DO AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE
COLLABORATIONS. THANK AS OUR
NEXT. GET READY LET ME GO AHEAD
AND JUST. REMIND EVERYONE THAT
WILL BE TAKING PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FOLLOWING THIS AGENDA ITEM THE
NUMBER TO CALL AND IS.
877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. FOR PLANNING PURPOSES WE
ANTICIPATE STARTING PUBLIC
COMMENTS AROUND FOUR PM.
MEMBERS WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO
WELCOME MONACO TOWER OWNER OF
ONE DAY CLEANING AND EARLY
STAGE OF MICRO BUSINESS THAT
OVERCAME BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CHALLENGES WITH THE HELP OF
STATE FEDERAL LOCAL PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES WELCOME. WE ALSO
HAVE NICOLE MCDONALD OWNER OF
STEM ACADEMY- MATURE SMALL
BUSINESS THAT HAS SURVIVED
SIXTEEN PLUS MONTHS OF KOBE
NINETEEN RESTRICTIONS WHO IS
NOW LOOKING FOR CAPITAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND ADDING
STAFF TO REACH THE NEXT STAGE
IN HER BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT. WE
ALSO HAVE ANY MADERA CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER EAST BAY
ASIAN LOCAL DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION THAT
DEVELOPED A CO BID COMMERCIAL
TENANT RESILIENCY PROGRAM FOR
ITS COMMERCIAL PORTFOLIO THE
MAJORITY OF WHICH IS COMPRISED
OF MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESS ENTREPRENEUR
ENTERPRISES. THIS PANEL. IS
GOING TO BE A LITTLE DIFFERENT
FROM THE OTHERS THAT WE HAD
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY FAST
PACED AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE EACH OF OUR
PANELISTS TAKING TIME OFF FROM
RUNNING THEIR BUSINESS I DAY TO
DAY OERATION AND ORGANIZATIONS
TO JOIN US THIS AFTERNOON TO
MAXIMIZE OUR TIME WE'RE GOING
TO DISPENSE WITH THE FORMAL
PRESENTATION DEMONSTRATE TO
ENGAGEMENT AND DIALOGUE BETWEEN
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND OUR
PANELISTS. TO KICK OFF THE
SESSION WE HAVE ASKED EACH OF
OUR PANELISTS TO MAKE A TWO
MINUTE INTRODUCTION AND OPENING
STATEMENT ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES ARE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS OR AS AN ORGANIZATION
THAT SERVES WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES MISS- CHILE IF
YOU LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND TELL US A LITTLE ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WEDNESDAY
CLEANING. YES THANK YOU COULD
HAVE EVERYONE- SO WE PROVIDE
CLEANING SERVICES TO MULTI UNIT
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS AND
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS- YES WE
ARE NEW- THE START OF BUSINESS-
WE HAD A SUCCESSFUL START TO
THE TO THE LOWER ABLE TO OBTAIN
THROUGH THE- CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATION. BUT WE ARE STILL
DEALING WITH A LOT OF
CHALLENGES FROM CORPORATE-
WE'RE STILL IN NEED OF SOME
HELP- SO I'M VERY HAPPY THAT
YOU GUYS ARE WORKING ON A PLAN
OF RECOVERY- TO ASSIST THE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I MISS SO
CHAU AYE COULD FIGHT AT NACS-
MOVED TO MISS MCDONALD PLEASE
TELL US ABOUT YOURSELF AND YOUR
COMPANY. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHAEL MCDONALD I AM THE
FOUNDER OF TEAM ACADEMY HERE IN
CORONA CALIFORNIA- WE ARE THE
LOCAL ORGANIZATION THAT FOCUSES
ON PROVIDING STEM. EDUCATION
AND ENRICHMENT. PROGRAMS FOR
OUR CLIENTS MOST OF OUR CLIENTS
ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
PURSUING IN- EDUCATION OR OR
CAREER. OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
ARTS AND MATH. THANK YOU
MISSPELLED MR MADERA PLEASE
PROVIDE US WITH AN INTRODUCTION
OF EAST BAY ASIAN LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION AND
YOUR ROLE WITH THE CDC. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEND SOME TIME WITH YOU OUT MY
NAME IS ANDY MADERA- THE SEA OF
THE EAST ASIAN THE DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION ALSO KNOWN AS THE
POLICY. AT WE REFORM FOUNDED
FORTY SIX YEARS AGO THAT WERE A
NOT FOR PROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER- AND ACDC CAN
WE DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION THAT
WORKS WITH A DIVERSE
POPULATIONS OF THE STATE TO
BUILD HEALTHY VIBRANT. AND SAFE
NEIGHBORHOODS. AS MATCHING THE
ANCHORS CDC'S PLAY A VITAL ROLE
IN CREATING AND SAFEGUARDING
SPACES INTEGRAL TO HEALTHY
VIBRANT AND EQUITABLE
NEIGHBORHOODS. WE ALSO OVERSEE
A COMMERCIAL PERFIL YOU- THAT'S
LARGELY LOCATED IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WITH A
HISTORY OF DISINVESTMENT. BY
PROVIDING BELOW MARKET RATE
COMMERCIAL SPACE THE CDC SERVE
AS A LAUNCHING PAD FOR
NEIGHBORHOOD SERVING INTERFACES
OPERATED BY FIRST TIME BUSINESS
OWNERS AND A NURSE AND A
REPRESENTANTES BURNERS. THE
MAJORITY. OF WHICH ARE WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. SOME OF
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD HAVE BEEN FOR
MORE THAN A HUNDRED YEARS
SERVING AS A GATEWAY FOR
NEWCOMERS IMMIGRANTS. IN THE
CENTERS OF ART CULTURE AND
FOOD. AND DAILY LIFE FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT FRANKLY
WEREN'T WELCOME TO ANYWHERE
ELSE. CITY POLICY RECENTLY CAME
TOGETHER WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER
BASED IN THE FRUITVALE.
NEIGHBORHOOD IN OAKLAND.
CHINATOWN COMMUNITY AMONG
CORPORATIONS HAVE DISCO. AND
THE TENDERLOIN NEIGHBORHOOD
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION. TO
HIGHLIGHT THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT THAT THE PROLONGED
PANDEMIS HAVING. ON OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WE SERVE. AND
THE CDC'S THEMSELVES. AMONG OUR
FOR CV CDCS WE HAVE UP 240%
SUSTAINED DECLINE IN RENT
COLLECTIONS ARE PROJECTING FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL RENT
LOSSES COMMERCIAL WENT LOSSES.
THROUGH THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE REALLY
ANTICIPATED LOSSES TO CONTINUE.
THE STEEP LOSSES ALONG WITH
ENOUGH TAKEN COULD RELATED
HEALTH AND SAFETY EXPENSES
WOULD GENERATE A CASCADE OF
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES. THE CITY
SEES SEVEN FORCED TO FOR OWN
LOAN PAYMENTS DRIVE DOWN
EXISTING RESERVES LIMIT FUTURE
RESERVE DEPOSITS FOR NEEDED
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS AND
REPAIRS AND MAKE SUBSTANTIAL
CASH ADVANCES FROM A CORPORATE
SERVERS. THIS PUTS THE CDC'S
AND OUR COMMUNITY PROGRAMMING
OR FOR A HOUSING WELL CULTURAL
PLEASE KEEPING THAT WE SUPPORT.
IN JEOPARDY. A CITY SEES THE
FIGHT TO KEEP OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
AFFORDABLE TO LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS AND COMMUNITY SERVING
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS. IN
ORDER TO DEFEND CITY C. PLACE
KEEPERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND PRESERVE CULTURAL AND
ECONOMIC SPACES. WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO TALKING TO YOU MORE
ABOUT- AT THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR- IMMEDIATE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR CDC'S. THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU WELL LET ME
START WITH THE QUESTION OF FOR
THE WHOLE PANEL ABOUT
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS SEEN
RESOURCES FOR- NOT JUST
YOURSELF BUT PRIORITIES FOR
YOUR MEMBERS CAN YOU SHARE.
MAYBE TO TAKE AWAYS ARE KEY
MESSAGES YOU WANT TODAY ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO TAKE AWAY.
AGAIN CAN YOU SHARE MAYBE TWO
MESSAGES THAT YOU WANT OUR
COMMITTEE TO TAKE AWAY TODAY.
AND WE COULD START WITH WEATHER
LIKE TO BEGIN. OKAY BEEN
POINTED AT. I GUESS A COUPLE OF
MESSAGES- IT WAS SAID BEFORE
BUT AT THAT IN THERE ARE SOME
RESOURCES OUT THERE AND THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH RESOURCES
PRINTABLE SO WE'LL KNOW THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES ROLES
MONTH- FORTIN BUT- I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT- THOSE RESOURCES HAPPY
PROVIDED IN A WAY THAT'S
CULTURALLY COMPETENT. AND
YOU'VE HEARD THAT ALREADY TODAY
NOW PLAYING THIS TYPE OF-
DIRECT ACCESS NEED IS BETWEEN
TRUSTED PARTNERS SO WE HAVE
OVER A HUNDRED COMMERCIAL-
TENANTS AGAINST MANY OF WHOM
ARE REALLY STRUGGLING RIGHT
NOW- WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
THEM WITH I REALLY WANT TO ONE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. HELPING
THEM- TO CHANGE THE WAY THEIR
BUSINESSES ARE RUNNING SO
GETTING THEM ONLINE- CONNECTING
THEM WITH- THAT'LL BLOW OUT LOW
COST CAPITAL SOURCES. OF MAKING
SMALL GRANTS TO THEM. DOING IT
IN- WILL DOUBLE- DOING IT IN A
WAY THAT IS ACCESSIBLE TO THEM
MEETING THEM AT NIGHT- IT'S
REALLY. TIME CONSUMING ONE ON
ONE TYPE OF AID- THAT. THAT
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. THE CENTRAL. THE
RESOURCES ARE THERE- BUT IT
FEELS KINDA LIKE FROM MY
EXPERIENCE THAT THE PUT IN A
BOX. YOU GONNA MEET CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS ARE ALSO IT'S VERY
HARD TO. FIFTEEN WHERE YOU NEED.
I THINK- SOME BUSINESSES CAN
HAVE THEIR OWN UNIQUENESS. AND
IF. WE COULD HAVE LIKE A WAY TO
COLLECT HOW WHAT WAS ABLE TO
SPEAK TO RUTH GARCIA FROM THE-
BUSINESS AS CENTER AND LOS
ANGELES. AND HOW EXPLAINED TO
HER MY SITUATION. THEN SHE WAS
ABLE TO HE DON'T HAPPEN ON SOME
THINGS TO HELP ME GET TO WHERE
I NEEDED TO GET- BUT IF I
WOULDN'T HAVE HAD TO PUT IT IN
JUST TO SPEAK TO HER DIRECTLY
AND EXPRESSED TO HER. WHAT I
WAS LOOKING FOR AND WHAT I
NEEDED- I WOULD PROBABLY NOT BE
SITTING HERE GOOD MY BUSINESS
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET
STARTED. CAN WE MAYBE EXPAND ON
US HOPEFUL I WAS WONDERING
MAYBE PERHAPS WEB PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS THAT- MAYBE
UNINTENTIONALLY- WHICH INCLUDED
YOU FROM PARTICIPATING AND
GAINING ACCESS ARE YOU ABLE TO
SHED SOME LIGHT ON THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BEING PLACED IN A
BOX WHAT. WHAT DO WE DO TO
SOMEONE WITH MORE PROGRAMS IF
LIKE I REACH OUT TO SOME BUT
THE TRADITIONAL BANKING
INSTITUTIONS AND THEY REQUIRE
AT LEAST TWO YEARS OF TAX
RETURNS. I'M A NEW BUSINESS ON
OUR SITE AND I HAVE THAT. AND
THEN SOME OF THE MOST OF THE
STATE POGRAMS THE REQUIRED
pRETURNS. SO AS SOON AS YOU'RE
READING ON THE WEBSITE AND
THAT'S LIKE A REQUIREMENT IS
JUST LIKE DISCOURAGE YOU FROM
ONE OF CONTINUE. PUSHING
FORWARD. TO OBTAIN A LOAN OR TO
GET THE HELP. YEAH AND I WOULD
AGREE WITH THAT I THINK A LOT
OF OUR- A LOT OF MY TENANTS
THAT HAD TROUBLE ACCESSING
RESOURCES- I THINK- STATUS
CAMINO ISSUE- I THINK- AGAIN PP
P. WAS INITIALLY FOR MANY-
COMMERCIAL TENANTS WHO DIDN'T
QUALIFY BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN AROUND LONG ENOUGH OR
DIDN'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE
RECORD KEEPING TO SHOW THE
FOLLOWING REVENUE- AND- I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT. IT IS SORT OF A
GAP SO WE OURSELVES WENT OUT
AND DID A LOT OF FUND RAISING.
AND RAISE MONEY TO PROVIDE
SMALL GRANTS TO SOME OF OUR
TENANTS IN THE- THEN THE LIKE
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR RANGE.
THAT CAN HELP A LITTLE BIT BUT
REALLY THEY NEED THEY NEED MORE
THAN THAT- TO GET MORE THAN
THAT YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
WHOLE LOT OF OTHER RIGMAROLE
ORDER TRY TO FIND THE SOURCE
THAT'S NOT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE MILLION DOLLARS. BY TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS CAN BE VERY
MEANINGFUL- PARTICULARLY WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- SOME
BUSINESSES THAT ARE CAPITAL
INTENSIVE LIKE- RESTAURANTS
WHERE- THEY DO HAVE TO-
INVENTORY ISSUES- WITH A REALLY
THERE THEY HAVE A CASH NEED
THAT. DATA CAN BE LARGER THAN
SOME OTHER ONES. IF I COULD
TURN I MISS MADONNA I KNOW
WHO'S JOINING US REMOTELY ARE
THERE ARE TWO KEY MESSAGES YOU
WOULD LIKE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
TAKE AWAY. YES WHERE I THINK
FOR MANY- SMALL BUSINESSES WE
TYPICALLY STRUGGLE WHERE AT
LEAST YOU KNOW THE ONES OF I
WAS THAT INCLUDES CONTACT WITH-
CAPITAL. AND- AND INGROSSO
CAPITAL TO BE ABLE TO GROW AT
THE LAST SIXTEEN MONTHS MY
CLIENT BASE WIN GOLD- AND SO I
HAD TO HAVE IT AND IN ORDER FOR
ME TO HAVE ANY EFFECTIVELY-
THERE WAS- THAT I NEEDED TO
PURCHASE THAT I NEVER HAVE TO
PURCHASE BEFORE WE HAVE TO.
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD ENOUGH
COMPUTERS WILL MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE- INTERNET- AND WIFI
CAPABILITIES- EXPECTATION. TO
ENSURE THAT OUR CLIENTS THAT
WERE MUCH NEEDED OF OUR
SERVICES. HAD TRANSPORTATION TO
COME TO OUR CENTRES AND THOSE
ARE STUDENTS THAT WERE
STRUGGLING PARTICULARLY IN
MATH. AND DOING REMOTE TO
DURING A REMOTE ACADEMIC
SUPPORT WAS JUST- IT DIDN'T
THAT WAS THE LEAST EFFECTIVE
MEANS SO. WE REALLY DID HAVE-
YOU KNOW JUST TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW THE- YEP AND
THEN MAKE IMPACT THAT. I WHEN
APPLYING FOR PPP I CAN YOU BOTH
THE PPP GRANTS AND FOR SBA
LOANS- GRATEFUL TO RECEIVE
DEMOCRATS NEED TO EDIT BUT THE
REALITY WAS THAT- IT REALLY
COVERED ONE MONTH RIGHT FOR US.
AND SO ARE A LOT OF SLEEPLESS
NIGHTS- ARE THAT WAS JERRY-
THERE WAS A LACK OF RESOURCES
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT WE
COULD HAVE REALLY TAPPED INTO
NOT JEFF BARNES. BUT PROGRAMS
IN WHICH- AT WORK CALL FIGHT TO
OBTAIN. A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT
IS THE FEDERAL- WORK PROGRAMS
THAT WE WOULD HAVE LOVED TO BE
ABLE TO TAP INTO- AND BE ABLE
TO HIRE STUDENTS AT THE LOCAL
UNIVERSITIES- TO HELP US. AND
THAT THAT YOU KNOW OF COURSE
THAT WAS NOT AVAILABLE TO US
TO- THOSE FUNDS FOR DESIGNATED
FOR. ON CAMPUS. JOBS I. SO WE-
BUT A GREAT DEAL WE OPENED UP
OUR DOORS A BIT MORE TO HOME
SCHOOL FAMILIES- BUT THE
REALITY BE BEHIND THAT IS THAT
THERE WAS SOME RESTRICTIONS
THERE TO- BUT I THINK FOR BRASS
HURRIEDLY CAPITAL CONTINUES TO
BE A STRUGGLE- STAFFING IS A
HUGE- CHALLENGE FOR US RIGHT
NOW. WE ARE NOT ABLE TO HIRE
THE- PEOPLE THAT WE TYPICALLY
HIGHER- RIGHT NOW THE LABOR
COST IS GONNA. SO EVERYTHING IN
RELATIONS TO LABOR HAS GONE OUT
FOR US WORKERS COMP INSURANCE
IS GONNA- WE ARE STRUGGLING
RIGHT NOW WHERE NOW MOST
FAMILIES ARE GOING BACK TO
SCHOOL- WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO. TAP INTO THAT MARKET BUT IT
CAN ARM WE DON'T HAVE THE STAFF
ITSELF YOU LOOK ACROSS THE
STREET FROM US WE SEE A BIG
SIGN TO MAKE DONALD AND LARGER
CORPORATIONS EITHER CAME IN-
STUDENT LOANS OR INCREASE IN
THEIR WAGES I WOULD. WE'RE
WE'RE NOT COMPETITIVE ENOUGH
SO- HIRING HAS BECOME EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESSES. RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU MISTER DONALD ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. FOR MY CHAIR. THAT'S
WHY I ACTUALLY TO PICK UP ON
ONE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HEARD
IN OUR FIRST HOUSE ALSO ON MS
FONG KUSHIDA ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THAT SHE POINTED TO WAS-
AS THE NEED FOR REGULATORY
MODERNIZATION AND REMOVING
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS IN ACCESS TO
GOVERNMENT SERVICES AND
COMPLIANCE- AND SHE
SPECIFICALLY SPOKE OF THE NEED
TO STREAMLINE. OUR LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAM. I'D LOVE TO
HEAR YOUR PERSPECTIVES ON
NAVIGATING THE STATE'S
BUREAUCRACY AS PART OF WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN BEEN DOING ON
NUMBER ONE AND THE NUMBER TWO
ARE THERE ANY SPECIFIC OTHER
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES OF STATE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU THINK NEED TO
BE STREAMLINED AND SIMPLIFIED
TO MAKE ACCESS. EASIER. WELL
YES I DIDN'T COME TO LIKE I
SAID EARLIER THIS IS LIKE THE
PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO PUT IN A
BOX AND IF WE CAN MAYBE HAVE
LIKE FOUR BRAND NEW BUSINESSES
AND THEN HERE'S YOUR PACKAGE
THIS IS WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS
WILL BE- AND THEY BEGIN THAT
TO. PEOPLE THAT WOULD IN THE
INDUSTRY WITH A LITTLE LONGER
MAYBE TWO THREE YEARS- BECAUSE
THE CHALLENGES VERY DEPENDING
ON HOW LONG YOU'VE BEEN IN THE
YOUR BUSINESS. YOU KNOW THE
DAYS WHEN YOU USED TO WILL YOU
BE IN TEN YEARS IN THE BUSINESS-
SO I GUESS YOU KNOW LIKE IF THE
REQUIREMENTS CAN BE. DEPENDING
ON WHETHER YOUR START UP OR TWO
YEARS THREE YEARS TEN YEARS I
THINK IT'LL MAKE IT A LOT
EASIER- THAN JUST GOING IN AND
READ. IT MOST OF THE PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY DESCRIBED THE WHOLE
PACKAGE AND IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
FOR COMPANIES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THE BUSINESS. FOR MANY YEARS.
AND THEN SAUCE THAT'S HOW
YOU'RE GOING THROUGH THE
REQUIREMENTS. THE YESTERDAY WE
DIDN'T LIKE HOW FOR THOSE
REQUIREMENTS IS THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO QUALIFY FOR.
THEN THE COULD BE SOME OTHER
OPTIONS. LIKE IF THEY PUT IT
YOU KNOW FROM THE BEGINNING ON
THE WEB SO LET'S JUST BREAK IT
DOWN. SURVEYCOMPARE REYES SAID
I THINK WHAT I HEAR YOU SAYING
IS THERE NEEDS TO BE- BETTER
TRANSPARENCY AND CLARITY. UP
FRONT- RATHER THAN HAVE MAKING
YOU GO DOWN THIS WINDING ROAD.
HITTING A DEAD END. TAKING A
TURN EXACTLY YES. THANK YOU.
OTHER THOUGHTS CHECK I GUESS I
WOULD ASK THAT- IN I THINK
THAT- IS- REMAINS THERE. SO
EXEMPLIFIED A LOT OF THESE
POINTS BUT BASICALLY. A LOT OF
OUR COMMERCIAL TENANTS THEY
REALLY THEY REALLY NEED VERY
CLOSE ONE ON ONE. HELP IN
TRYING TO ACCESS PROGRAMS HOW
TO EVEN MAKE APPLICATION- HOW
DO YOU EVEN- THERE'S A LOT OF
LANGUAGE BARRIERS THERE'S A LOT
OF- GOT CULTURAL COMPETENCY
ISSUES. AND THE WAY IN WHICH WE
ENSURE THAT REALLY SOME OF OUR-
OUR OUR BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES CAN ACCESS THESE
PROGRAMS IS WHEN THEY HAVE
TRUSTED PARTNERS. SO THE CDC'S
THE CDFI IS. THE NEIGHBORHOOD
ORGANIZATIONS THAT A LOT OF
OUR- A LOT OF A BUSINESS IS
ALREADY HAVE CONTACT WITH. I
REALLY A GREAT ACCESS POINT TO
HELP THEM- EIGHT YOU MIGHT
THINK ABOUT IT AS- SIMILAR TO
YOU'RE SEEING A LOT OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH AMBASSADORS
NOW. SO IN OUR EFFORTS TO TRY
TO INCREASE THE VACCINATION
RATES AMONG OUR BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES WE REALLY GETTING
PEOPLE LITERALLY OUT ON THE
STREETS- FRED WITH THEIR PEERS
WHO ARE HELPING THEM- TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
VACCINATION. VERY SIMILAR WAY
ON THE- ON THE COMMERCIAL SIDE
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO TURN TO DON'T SPEAK
THE LANGUAGE. AND ARE SUPER
BUSY- SO WE'RE MEETING PEOPLE
AT NIGHT. IN THEIR RESTAURANTS
WE HAVE- WE HAVE A ONE OF OUR
PARTNERS- IT'S CALLED GOOD GOOD
EATS. AND IT'S REALLY TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE HELPING- HELPING
BUSINESSES. TRANSIT FOR THEIR
WORK ON TO SOCIAL MEDIA THEY'RE
LITERALLY GOING INTO THE
RESTAURANTS TAKING PICTURES FOR
THEM SHOWING THEM HOW TO USE
YOU KNOW THE PHONE IN ORDER TO
YOU KNOW REACH OUT AND TAKE
ORDERS AND- YOU KNOW WE'RE
HELPING THEM SET UP PORTLETS.
BUT IT IT TAKES ONE ON ONE TIME
INTENSIVE- CONNECTION WITH
COMMUNITIES. AND IN YOUR VIEW
IS THAT- IS IT A CHALLENGE OF
OUR NETWORK OF TRUSTED PARTNERS
NEEDING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES SO
THAT THEY CAN CAN PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT YES ARE YOU
ALSO NEED TO GROW OUR NETWORK.
OF A FAD TRUSTED STATE PARTNERS
EXACTLY- IS THAT WE KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE DOING IT BECAUSE WE WENT
OUT AND BASICALLY REYES GRANT
MONEY FROM SOME BANKS TO DO IT-
EIGHT EIGHT AND WE DID IT
BECAUSE IT WAS REALLY AN
EMERGENCY- WE NEEDED TO HELP
OUR- COMMERCIAL TENANTS
BECAUSE- WHERE THEIR LANDLORD
AND- HAVE YOU KNOW WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL SO THAT WE STATE
SUCCESSFUL- BUT- IT IS ON SUCH
A- LIMITED SCALE. YOU KNOW IT'S
US A HUNDRED A HUNDRED TO
BUSINESSES. HOW MANY OTHER
BUSINESSES ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
THE SAME POSITION- WE ALSO I
THINK. IN A SHOULD BE MINDFUL
OF THAT- YOU KNOW CAN WE BEAT
THE THIRD DISPARITY IMPACT IS
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT I THINK IT'S
BASICALLY A LOT OF OUR FIRST
PANELIST TALKED ABOUT THAT. ARE
ARE AGAIN OBSERVE BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES ARE REALLY
BEEN HIT HARDEST BY COULD. HAVE
REALLY BEEN HIT HARDEST BY A
LOT OF THE- SHUT DOWN- AND IN
CALIFORNIA OR CHINA TUNES-
BRIDGEPORT WAS HIT EARLY- AND
HAVE CONTINUED TO SUSTAIN- A
LOT OF- REDUCTION IN THIS IS
THAT IT. STEPS VERY SIGNIFICANT
AND ENDANGERS THEIR CONTINUED
SUSTAINABILITY. WE DON'T WANT
TO SEE OUR SORT OF CULTURAL
CENTERS GO AWAY. SO WE REALLY
NEED TO SUPPORT THEM. AND WE
NEED TO SUPPORT THE QUICKLY
BEYOND I'M WORRIED THAT WE
WE'VE ENDED THE BUDGETARY
SECESSION- AND- BUT YEAH WE
REALLY NEED HELP FOR
BUSINESSES. REALLY NOW. CARE
AND MS MCCONNELL TO THEM I LIKE
TO PICK IT BACK ON THAT- IN
WHICH IMPLICIT IN PARTICULAR
WITH THE AFRICAN AMERICAN.
BUSINESS COMMUNITIES- ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT I NOTICED
FOR MYSELF AS WELL AS WITH SOME
OF THE OTHER- BUSINESSES. WAS
EXACTLY THAT THE PARTNERSHIP-
YOU OBTAIN FIND IN- AND
EXCESSIVE AND ACCESS TO SOME OF
THE FUNDING AND PROGRAMS- MOST
OF THEM WENT THROUGH AB.
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WHETHER
THEY WERE COMMUNITY FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS OR OR BIG BANKS- I
THINK THAT WAS THE LEAST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO GET THESE
PROGRAMS WHO TO THE COMMUNITY-
I TRULY THOUGHT THAT. IT WAS
ALMOST- YEAH- YOU KNOW IT
WITHOUT YOU KNOW. IT SOUNDED.
THAT WAY INTENTIONAL AND SO I
KNOW FOR MYSELF- GETTING ON
FACEBOOK IN POSTING IN IN
TRYING TO GET OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY- TO THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN BLACK COMMUNITY THAT
THERE IS FINDING OUT THERE IS
EASE OF THE PROCESSES THAT YOU
WOULD NEED TO TAKE- AND THEN
THAT WAS YOU KNOW MY PARTICULAR
EFFORT SO. I WANT TO FEEDBACK
ON THAT COMMENT IS YOU KNOW CAN
WE PARTNER. WITH UNITY ARE
EXIST BUSINESS. WE IN THE CAN.
NOT NECESSARILY BUSINESS NOT
NECESSARILY- INSTITUTIONS THAT-
AND THAT MAY BE- YOU KNOW
DESIGNED FOR THIS BUT YOU KNOW
I THE BARBER SHOP IN THE- YOU
KNOW THE RESTAURANTSAND HOSTED
HAVING A FORMAL- ACCESSIBILITY
OR FORMAL PROCESS WHICH PEOPLE
CAN UTILIZE ACCESS. PROGRAMS
SIX FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
PARTICULARLY FOR THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS- AS YOU
KNOWLEDGE WITH THE DATA THAT'S
BEEN SHOWN THROUGHOUT THE LAST
FEW HOURS. WE ARE AT AN ORGANIC
OR WE ARE A COMMUNITY IT'S BEEN
EXTREMELY HARD EXTREMELY HARD
AND WE STARTED STARTED. BEFORE
CLOTHING AND DOWN IT JUST
BASICALLY I GOT A LOT WORSE SO
I THINK IN PARTICULAR BEING AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN. AND AT
LEAST YOU KNOW NAVIGATING
THROUGH THESE LAST SIXTY NINE.
THAT WOULD BE ONE OF MY
RECOMMENDATIONS IS TO- WORK
WITH COMMUNITIES. AND COMMUNITY
BUSINESSES SMALL COMMUNITY
BUSINESSES TO HELP-
ACCESSIBILITY TO SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU YEAH I
WOULD AGREE SEEN AS WELL WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE INTENTIONAL ABOUT THE WAY
THAT WE SHAPE THESE PROGRAMS
ARE RUN AMOUNT- TO ENSURE THAT.
WE HAVE THE OUTCOMES AT THE
TIME THAT WE WANT TO SEE FOR
THE STATE. WELL WHY I DO WANT
TO JUST KNOW WELL SAID- POINT
TAKEN MISS MCDONALD I IN FACT.
JURIED THESE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT MY
STATE OFFICE HAS BEEN DOING IS
DIRECTLY COLLEEN OUR SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY- MEMBERS ARE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
NONPROFITS AND- LETTING THEM
KNOW. WHERE AND HOW THEY CAN
APPLY I TO THESE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS- THAT THE STATE IS
FINDING. DURING THESE
CHALLENGES AND SO I JUST THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS I DO
WANT TO TURN TO ANOTHER
QUESTION FOR OUR PANELIST DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
WORDS OF ADVICE TO OTHER
BUSINESS OWNERS OR
ORGANIZATIONS NAVIGATING THE
COVE IN NINETEEN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. YES I WOULD DAM I
WOULD SAY AB. HAS BECOME MY NEW
WORDS FOR THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS- WHERE YOU STARTED MAY
NOT WHO ARE YOU AND- MY BIGGEST
ADVICE TO YOU ALL SMALL
BUSINESSES IS THAT SOMETIMES WE
HAVE TO MOVE OUTSIDE OF OUR
COMFORT ZONE AND DO THINGS THAT
WERE OR WERE NOT FAMILIAR WITH
AND DO THINGS THAT- ARE BIT
MORE RISKIER. SO YOU KNOW TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION ANY
ADVICE- TO HELP. MINORITY AND
WOMEN- SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
WOULD BE MY BY. YEAH THAT WOULD
BE MY ADVICE. THANK A MISPRINT
DONALD. ANY THOUGHTS FROM OUR
TOUR THE PANELIST. YEAH I WOULD
SAY TO REACH OUT. DON'T STAY
QUIET. BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T
MAKE ANY NOISE AND HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
HELP HOW ARE YOU GOING TO GET
TO BE ABLE TO CROSS. THE WALLS.
SO DON'T GIVE UP. JUST REACHING
OUT- SOMEONE WILL LISTEN.
SOMEONE WILL LISTEN PEOPLE DO
LISTEN PEOPLE DON'T CARE AND-
AND THEN IT WAS HARD FOR
EVERYONE. AND I THINK IN SOME
WAYS HE MADE US MORE AWARE OF
THE NEEDS OF OTHERS. SO THIS IS
THE TIME TO REALLY SPEAK OUT OF
REACH OUT AND- LAKE NICOLE WAS
SAYING YOU KNOW WITHIN US THE
SMALL BUSINESSES WE SHOULD
SUPPORT EACH OTHER'S BUSINESS.
NOT JUST WILL NOT FINANCE-
FINANCES ADDITIONS TO GIVE US A
LOAN SO THE GRASS. BUT IF
THERE'S ANYTHING WE CAN DO LIKE.
GIVE YOUR BUSINESS HOW CAN. FOR
A YOU KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR KIDS
AROUND THE- NICHOLS AREA AND
YOU CAN TAKE ON THEIR BAG THE-
YOU HAVE FRIENDS IN THAT AREA.
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST SUPPORT EACH
OTHERS WITH THE WITH YOUR
BUSINESS AND EVERY CHILD TO
SPEAK UP. SO I WOULD REALLY
AGREE WITH BOTH OF THOSE
SENTIMENTS ANY TICKET THAT THE
COMMUNICATION PORTION- IF THAT
IS ESSENTIAL. AND DO IT AGAIN
WELL OUR OUR OUR SMALL
BUSINESS- ARE TENANTS AT THE
THOSE THAT ARE THAT HAVE
REACHED OUT TO US FOR THE ONES
THAT WE ARE MOST ABLE TO HELP-
AND CONNECT WITH- THEY'RE ALSO-
ARE ABLE TO SORT OF LEARN FROM
EACH OTHER ABOUT WHAT WORKS
AND- AND WHAT DOESN'T WORK- I
WOULD. I WOULD SAY THAT- AS- WE
ALSO NEED TO WE ARE THIS IS ALL
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC RIGHT I MEAN
IT IT IS ABOUT SMALL BUSINESSES
SINCE BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC AND TO REALLY YOU KNOW
WE- CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE OUR
COMMUNITY TO- TO MASK UP WE-
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE OUR
COMMUNITY TO- TO GET
VACCINATED- AND WE WILL HELP
THEM. THEM WITH THAT AND
CONNECT THEM WITH RESOURCES- I
THINK B. THE LAST PIECE THAT
AGAIN IS THAT M. WE ALSO NEED
TO KEEP ASKING FOR HELP- I MEAN
YOU KNOW THE END OF THE DAY YOU
KNOW PART OF WHAT MOTIVATES ME
TO BE HERE IS TO BE ABLE TO
ASSIST OUR COMMUNITY. BUT
FRANKLY ALSO- TO RECOGNIZE THAT
AND- AT THE- THE NONPROFIT CDCS
WERE ALSO IN THIS BILL TO- AND
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING FOR- FOR
HELP FROM THE STATE- I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE THERE
IS SOME LEGISLATION THAT YOU
GUYS ARE- LOOKING AT- AND I.
GET THE NUMBER WRONG HERE BUT I
THINK IT'S- LOOK FOR TONY FOR
HELP HERE BUT IT'S LIKE AB
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN SO IT IS.
RUNNING AROUND. ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN OKAY- BASICALLY- YOU KNOW
AT. THAT YOU COULD SET A CREDIT-
IN THE STATE- RELIEF- I WILL
SAY TAXES WOULD BE GREAT- THERE
ARE SOME INDIRECT MEANS BY
WHICH MAYBE- THAT THE STATE CAN
HELP US FINANCIALLY. BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE STATE HELPS THE
NONPROFIT COMMERCIAL LANDLORDS
AND WE CAN TURN AROUND AND
CONTINUE TO HELP OUR- OUR SMALL
BUSINESS TENANTS AS WELL. THANK
YOU MISTER MADERA ANY FINAL
QUESTIONS. MARK COMMITTEE SO I
DO WANT TO JUST PERSONALLY I
THINK- MISTER MADERA MISTER
TROY MISSED MCDONNELL ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR JOINING US
TODAY FOR GIVING YOUR TIMING
JUST EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE FOR
YOUR INSIGHTS AND ADVICE- AND
JUST CONTINUE DOING THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING BACK HOME AND
AS WE ALL CONTINUE TO PAVE IT
AND PUSH FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH FOR LISTENING. AND THAT AS
WE TRANSITION TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF OUR HEARING
NOTICE ALSO ECHO LAST YEAR'S
ABOUT HIS THANKS- IN YOUR YOUR
FINAL COMMENTS YOU WERE YOU
WERE SPEAKING TO HE AT THE
FLEXIBILITY THE INGENUITY AND I
THINK THE TENACITY- THAT
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE
SHOWN THROUGHOUT THIS CRISIS
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE SUCH
KEY INGREDIENTS- AS WE- AS
WE'VE- MOVE THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC- BEGIN TO. TO REBEL
AND- THE BILL BACK UNDER ON SET
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
AND DEBORAH WILL NOW GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF THE HEARING. AS I
NOTED IN THE BEGINNING WE HAVE
THIRTY MINUTES TO HEAR PUBLIC
COMMENTS. FOR ANYONE DIALING IN
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE
ARE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
pNUMBER FOR THE HEARING AIDS
ONCE AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY JOBS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. WHEN YOU CALL
IN THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE.
JUST EMINDER IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE ANY SOUND DISTORTION.
AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER IF
YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE JOBS
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
ZERO. AND FOR THOSE WHO WOULD
PREFER TO OFFER WRITTEN
COMMENTS WRITTEN COMMENTS CAN
BE SUBMITTED TO THE JOBS
COMMITTEE UNTIL SEPTEMBER
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
PLEASE SEND WRITTEN COMMENTS TO
AJ E. D. AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV AGAIN THIS INFORMATION IS.
ALSO AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE.
PUBLIC COMMENTS SHOULD BE LIMIT
TO MINUTES PER PERSON AND MORE
EXTENDED COMMENTS CAN BE
PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE SAID
WRITING- LET'S GO AHEAD AND
START A PUBLIC COMMENT WITH-
THE FOLKS THAT ARE JOINING US
IN THE GALLERY OF THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER. PLEASE LINE UP AND-
PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASK ON WHILE
SPEAKING. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME'S LISA PETERSON OWNER
OF M. PRINCIPLE. OF RANDY
PETERS CATERING EVENT CENTER
AND ONE OH FIVE NINE THREE-
CATERING AND RESTAURANT
BUSINESS IN ROSEVILLE. I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE ROSEVILLE AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING YOU CAN THE UNITED
CHAMBER ADVOCACY NETWORK A
COALITION OF SEVEN LOCAL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE AND THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO REGION- I
JUST WANNA SAY FIRST THANK YOU
LEGISLATIVE FOR BRINGING THIS
ALL. TO EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION
THANK YOU TO THE PANELISTS I'VE
ENJOYED HEARING YOU ALL SPEAK.
AND THANK YOU FOR REPRESENTING
SMALL BUSINESSES- THE EXTENDED
ENHANCE STATE AND FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS ARE
SLOWING OUR STATE'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND HINDERING
BUSINESSES ABILITY TO BUILD
BACK. EMPLOYER SURVEYS HAVE
SHOWN THE GOVERNMENT BENEFITS
ARE COMPETING WITH PRIVATE
SECTOR EMPLOYERS DISCOURAGING
PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYEES FROM
ACCEPTING OPEN POSITIONS. A
RECENT YOU CAN EMPLOYER SURVEY
FOUND THAT 78% OF EMPLOYERS
HAVE CURRENT JOB OPENINGS AND
AMONG THOSE 78% SAID THEY ARE
HAVING DIFFICULTY HIRING
EMPLOYEES. AND THAT THAT GROUP
FIFTY SIX SAID PROSPECTIVE
EMPLOYEES WOULD PREFER TO
ACCEPT CURRENT PUBLIC BENEFITS
THAN ACCEPT THE JOB. ME
PERSONALLY- WE'VE NOW HAD TO
RUN NUMEROUS ADS THAT ARE VERY
COSTLY AND WILL GAIN VERY
LITTLE RESPONSE. AND WHEN WE DO
GET A RESPONSE THEY DON'T EVEN
SHOW UP FOR THE INTERVIEWS.
IT'S BEEN VERY VERY DIFFICULT-
WE'VE EVEN HAD TO THIS LAST
WEEK CLOSE DOWN THE RESTAURANT
FOR ONE FULL DAY BECAUSE THE
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE COMING TO
WORK ARE EXHAUSTED. THEY'RE
WORKING SIX DAYS DOUBLE SHIFTS.
AND WE JUST FELT IT WAS RIGHT
EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
THE COMPANY. IT'S HARDER TO PAY
THE BILLS BUT IT'S BETTER FOR
THEM PLEASE. AND WHAT WE FOUND
SO FAR IS THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE THANKING US FOR IT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE EMPLOYEES
ARE WORKING VERY LONG HOURS.
LONG TIME ON THEIR FEET. SO IF
THE LEGISLATURE WON'T ROLL
THESE BENEFITS BACK AND STOP
THE GOVERNMENT FROM COMPETING
WITH THE SMALL BUSINESSES. FOR
EMPLOYEES AT THE VERY LEAST WE
SUGGEST LEGISLATOR PROVE IT- NO
EXPANSION AND NO EXTENSION OF
THE CURRENT SET OF BENEFITS.
YOU ALL SAY THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE RESILIENT AND WE
ARE. BUT WE CAN'T DO WITHOUT
EMPLOYEES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CLAUDIA VAGUE AND I AM THE
FOUNDER OF THE INVEST IN WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURS INITIATIVE AND
ALSO WORK AS THE ADVOCATE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTER NETWORK- LAST WEEK THE
WALL STREET JOURNAL REPORTED
THAT SMALL BUSINESS OPTIMISM IS
AT AN ALL TIME LOW EVEN LOWER
THAN DURING THE DOWN THE GREAT
RECESSION THIS IS A CALL FOR
HELP AND IT REALLY UNDER IS
UNDERLINED BY WHAT WE HEARD
FROM OUR PANELISTS EARLIER ON
THIS AFTERNOON OF THE NEED FOR
WRAPAROUND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AT ONE ON ONE THAT HOLISTIC
APPROACH. NEXT MONTH WE'RE
GOING TO BE LOSING TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDING IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN THE CARERS ACT
GOES AWAY. SO IT JUST MAKES SO
MUCH SENSE TO INCREASE FUNDING
FOR THE TAPE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EXPANSION PROGRAM
WITHIN GO BAD IS THAT WE DID
TALK ABOUT EARLIER. I REALLY
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO DOUBLE
THAT FUNDING AND THEN MAKE SURE
THAT ANY NEW PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING OFFERED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAD TO HAVE THEIR OWN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FUNDING TO
SO WE DON'T END UP ROBBING
PETER TO PAY PAUL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME THROUGH MY
MASK LORI KAMMER ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS AND SMALL
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA. IT'S GREAT
TO SEE YOU TODAY- I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD FROM SOME. AMAZING
SPEAKERS AMAZING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND- BUT THAT THE
STORIES THAT I'VE HEARD THE
STORIES THAT THEY HAVE SAID IN
A SPECIALLY THE WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS- IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
THAT THE- THE LAST YEAR AND
WHAT IT'S BEEN LIKE- TO PAY IF
IT IS ONE OF YOUR- ESTEEM
SPEAKERS HAD HAD MENTIONED AND
THAT'S KIND OF BEEN THE WORDS-
YOU KNOW THE- THE-
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT FORTH
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM FUND
PROGRAM. WE THINK IT'S A GREAT
IDEA WE ARE SO EXCITED WORKING
WITH SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTERS AND ALL THIS. SB TAPE
PROVIDERS TO GET THIS PROGRAM
UP ANDRUNNING AND TO BE ABLE
TO ATTRACT US START UPS SMALL
BUSINESSES MICROCOMPUTER EASE-
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
APPLICANTS- THAT THAT
APPLICATION GRANTS- WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
EXISTING SMALL BUSINESSES WHO
ARE MEMBERS OF SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS OF NOVEL
CALIFORNIA WHO RELY ON THE
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS THAT THEY IN FACT ARE
TAKEN CARE OF THAT THE FUNDING
IS NOT USE COMPLETELY THAT THE
S. B. R. SEES ME THAT. FUNDING
THAT GOES TO THAT SPECIES- IS
USED FOR THEIR EXISTING CLIENTS
AND WE HAVE MADE A BUDGET
REQUEST TO SEE IF WE CAN GET
ADDITIONAL FUNDING- THANK YOU
TO BE ABLE TO RUN THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM FUND AND
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR THE
WOMEN BUSINESS. OWNERS AS YOU
HAVE HEARD TODAY SO- WE
RESPECTED RESPECTFULLY- ASKED
TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS TO- HELP
US YOU KNOW I GET THAT MESSAGE
ACROSS. BOB. AND PAT PHONE
BECAUSE SHE THAT. EARLIER WITH
TO ALLOW THAT WAS SENT TO
EVERYONE JULY THE MEMBERS JULY.
FOURTEENTH IN THAT THERE WERE
SEVENTEEN ASSOCIATIONS WHO
REPRESENT THE INTERESTS OF
SMALL BUSINESS IN ADDITION TO
NAPO SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA.
ALSO IN THE MONTH OF JUNE MAY
AND JUNE WE WERE ABLE TO
COLLECT FIVE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
LETTERSFIVE HUNDRED FIFTY AS A
MATTER OF FACT- EXACTLY. BOB
FROM SMALL BUSINESSES WHO HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM THE WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS AND THE SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS.
AND ALL OF THE SMALL BUSINESS-
TECHNICAL PROVIDERS AND SO
EVERY SINGLE LETTER HAD A
STORY- AND I'VE READ NOT ALL OF
THEM BUT MOST OF THEM BUT EVERY
SINGLE ONE WAS PERSONAL. I'LL
MAKE SURE IN AND- THE
COMMITTEE- HAS RECEIVED ACTIONS
AND MAKE SURE THE COMMITTEE HAS
RECEIVED. A PDF OF ALL OF THOSE
LETTERS SEVERAL PDF- I WILL
MAKE SURE TO GET THOSE PRINTED
IN AND TO GET THEM INTO THE
HANDS OF THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE
THE LETTERS ARE AMAZING- AND
IT'S A GOOD. TELLS A GREAT
STORY FROM FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
COMPANIES HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
THE SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS WOMEN BUSINESS CENTER
SO I THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. OPTUS SESSION ON THAT
MEETING THE FUNDING NEEDS OF
THE WOMEN BUSINESSES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF THERE ANYONE IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN THE GALLERY YEARS THAT
THAT'S ALL OF OUR OKAY- WELL.
OKAY I WITH THAT- OPERATOR IF
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND- OPEN THE
LINE FOR OUR FIRST- COLOR. THEY
THEN DETERMINE IF YOU NEED TO
MAKE A COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT A PRESS ONE ZERO. JUST
A MOMENT.
OKAY WE GO TO LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MICHELLE
SKELTON I SERVICE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND COACHELLA VALLEY WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS. WE ARE
PROGRAMS OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
CENTER FOR ENTREPRENEURSHIP AT
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY SAN
BERNADINO. IN THE NUMBER
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER ALONG
WITH ALL SIXTEEN WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
LIFELINE OF SUPPORT
ENCOURAGEMENT. ACCESS TO RESORT
SOURCES AND SO MUCH MORE TO THE
WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS THAT HAVE
NEEDED ASSISTANCE THROUGHOUT
THIS PAST YEAR. I W. B. C.
SUPPORTED 70% MORE CLIENTELE
OVER THIS PAST YEAR IN THE
PRIOR YEAR. AND THERE REQUESTS
FOR ASSISTANCE HAVE NOT
DECLINED. ADDITIONALLY IF 75%
OF THE CLIENTS WERE NEW CLIENTS
SERVED. EVEN WITH THE HIGH
DEMAND FOR SERVICES I A. W. B.
HE WAS ABLE TO EXPAND SERVICES
BY HOSTING A WOMAN OF COLOR
SUCCESS HEARING WE LAUNCHED A
W. B. C. DOT COM WE POWER
HIGHLIGHTED A ENTREPRENEUR TO
EMPLOYER PROGRAM. AND HOW THE
KAUFMAN FAST TRACK SUMMER START
PROGRAM. IT IS OUR GENUINE
CONCERN FOR THE SUCCESS AND
WELL BEING OF OUR CLIENTS THAT
MAKES US UNIQUE AND IT THE
CENTRAL ASSET TO THE
UNDERSERVED WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS IN OUR REGION. I
PERSONALLY HAVE DEDICATED
NEARLY EIGHTEEN YEARS TO THE
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER PROGRAM
BECAUSE I SO STRONGLY BELIEVE
IN OUR VISION OF EMPOWERING
WOMEN THROUGH ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
I WANT TO THANK YOU YOUR
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORTING THE
VITALLY IMPORTANT SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS SO
GREATLY NEEDED AND APPRECIATED
THANK YOU. YEAH. MEXICO
CAROLINA TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS HEIDI
PICKMAN I'M WITH CANYON THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
MICRO ENTERPRISE AND ENTERPRISE
OPPORTUNITY AND I JUST WANTED
THAT SAYING- BOWS AND CHAIRS
FOR THE JOINT HEARING I THINK
IT'S- IT HIGHLIGHTED SUPER
IMPORTANT ISSUES I'M GLAD WE'RE
GETTING IT ON THE RECORD- AND
YOU CAN TELL- FROM GERMAN AND
ON THE PADS AND NANCY'S.
TESTIMONY IN THE BUSINESS
OWNER'S TESTIMONY HI EVERYONE
HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN THE MODEL
DEVELOPMENT HE TOOK THEM- AND
COMING BROUGHT ME TO TEARS WITH
ONE- YOU KNOW WHAT THE STORY OF
THE PARAMOUNT- I DIDN'T THESE
ARE YOU CAN TELL THAT THESE ARE
THE LIFEBLOOD OF OUR COMMUNITY-
DAY MOL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS IN THE WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTERS THE P. TAXES FOR
CHAPTERS THEY BEEN DOING AN
AMAZING JOB KEEPING- THE
BUSINESSES UPLOAD AND NOW THEIR
NEXT. THEIR NEXT STEP IS TO
LEAVE BOTH BUSINESS AND TOWARD
RECOVERY AND THAT THEIR PUT
THEIR RESOURCES NEED TO BE
SPENT ON THAT- THE DREAM SIGNED
IT A NEW PROGRAM WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT I THINK THE BRING
FUNDED THE GREAT PROGRAM- NO
DIFFERENT THAN THE HE PROGRAM
COULD TAKE MONEY GOES DIRECTLY
TO THE ORDER BUT THE- YOU CAN
DOLLARS WILL GO TO- IF YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS-
GRANDFATHER WHINING AND THIS
IS. A WE ARE GOING TO GO TO ONE
HUNDRED SHARED OUR MENTORING
BENEFITING THANK YOUNG FELLOWS
AND CARMEN MENTIONED- I. G.
SPENDING- TEN OUR BRIAN ON
HELPING PEOPLE YOU KNOW GET
HAPPENED THE GATHERED TOGETHER
FOR THEY NEED TO GATHER SO THAT
THEY CAN APPLY FOR THEM-
CALIFORNIA- LEAGUE GRANT. THAT
DOES. THE OTHER PLACES THAT WE
CAN FIND- THE MONEY FOR THE
GREEN LINE PA THE THINGS I
HIGHLY SUPPORT THAT AND KEEPING
A STATE PROGRAM CALL AND I ALSO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL
THE BUSINESS ON OUR TO DO ARE
DOING THE WORK OF KEEPING UP
COMMUNITY- TOGETHER. AT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TIFFANY MARC REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS WHICH REPRESENTS
FARMERS WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY WOMEN AND
MINORITY FARMERS. I WANTED TO
THANK THE CHURCH FOR HOSTING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING AND
FEATURING INSPIRING PANELISTS.
WHILE THE HEARING FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON SB A LOANS AND THE
CHALLENGES OF. BUSINESS OWNERS
THE TOPIC APPLIED ALMOST
IDENTICALLY TO THE CHALLENGES
THAT CASF ARMOR SPACE AS SUCH
WE WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR
INVESTMENTS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO WHAT HER FOCUS
ON MINORITY AND WOMEN FARMERS
AND URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
COMPLEMENT THAT WITH SUPPORTING
DIRECT RELIEF FOR THE FARMERS
WHO ARE SUFFERING DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND ALSO. FOR FARMERS
THE DROUGHT. FURTHER IF YOU
WERE INSPIRED BY FIVE WAS BY MR
ERA MANAGERS. ABOUT HER IN.
KAPUSO A BY FOR TO SUPPORT
CREATING TO APPLY THE LUNCH
CREATE. SHE MENTION AND HOPE
YOU CAN SUPPORT AS WELL.
NEITHER DID YOU. WITHOUT A PART
OF THE FUN PACKED THAT PASSED
REQUESTED AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
FOLLOWING UP WITH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. TO URGE THEIR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU. AND
AT THE TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
AT. MEMBERS I'D BE FOUND AT
TODAY'S HEARING AS INTERESTING
AND INSIGHTFUL AS I DID- BEFORE
WE HAVE WE CLOSE TODAY WITH ANY
MEMBERS LIKE TO MAKE CLOSING
REMARKS. ALL RIGHT WELL WITH
THAT I. HEARINGS LIKE THIS ARE
SO IMPORTANT FOR US AS POLICY
MAKERS ON THEY REALLY ARE
FOUNDATIONAL AS WE WORK TO
DEVELOP POLICIES TO. SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESSES CREATE GOOD
JOBS. CREATE MORE CALIFORNIA
ENTREPRENEURS AND OPEN MORE
WINDOWS UP OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
MORE COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS OUR
STATE AS I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE AGAIN FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO PARTNER WITH
YOU AS THAT WE DO YOU THE
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT AND
CRITICAL WORK OF SUPPORTING OUR
MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES ALL ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND WITH THAT WE
ARE TURNED.